redact
so Peter would like to
take have you do you are you prepared to
switch it out right now we just we
can protect it very quickly oh
can we have your and the clerks
binders and we're just gonna blacken out
a little piece of personal information
that we didn't catch earlier
absolutely
your honor I just want to be clear on
something
as I recall plans filed emotion
that we weren't going to comment on
Mr Sanderson if he was not present all
of the time
and yet I was surprised to hear play
enough
uh bring that out with Sam Goldstein
that was an entirely new opinion
entirely
broadside that Goldstein now had advised
Mr Sanderson
that it wouldn't be good for him in part
because Mr Sanderson does not take
criticism well
I
think that was violative of the Court's
order
which again was made on plaintiff's own
motion
and
um
I think that's now open game because the
the door has been opened I
so I I don't know how to address it
except for the jury now knows on the
advice of his therapist
that
it's not healthy for Mr Sanderson to be
here so I I just want to know I everyone
to know I I may bring it up now
because it has been brought up
hey what part of the order came out of
that motion pre-trial motion thank you
perhaps my memory fails me that it was a
formal Motion versus an informal
conversation I'd be interested in
playing plaintiff's memory on that
I know there was some discussion of it I
thought there was a motion
I mean it's not your honor can you
repeat that I'm sorry
I I recall there being conversation
about it I mean some argument and
discussion formally and I don't recall
whether there was a I I think there was
some kind of emotion from the plaintiff
and Peter's telling me uh that it was
discussed but perhaps didn't make it
into the written order
I'd be interested in playing up some
memory of that
courts
okay
maybe you could find it uh Peter in the
in the in the papers and we can address
it during a break and mostly I guess uh
it sounds like I'm not restricted then
from talking about it that mostly I was
concerned like in my trouble for
bringing it up but it sounds like it's
not in a written order and if they have
brought it up
I'm okay that's that's was my goal in
bringing it up
it depends on what they bring up I'm not
sure what he's prospering right now it's
hard to
talk about something I don't know about
yet
okay
thank you
anything else
uh
Bob Sykes was kind enough to call me
last night and say that they intend to
call Gwyneth Paltrow before Terry
Sanders is that still the case
Sanderson That was supposed to be a
private phone call Steve I I didn't know
that but I do need to bring this up
because if they're supposed to rest
today
but if you tell me this needs to be
private I'll we'll keep it private but
you didn't say that about a minute with
counsel and talk about it
uh if it's not going to be this morning
we can do it this afternoon why don't we
wait okay thank you
by the way Bob I was complimenting you
for for being upfront with me so I I it
wasn't a diss
please no more compliments
from you
any more issues before the jury comes in
can you queue up the video and get it
ready
and are we ready to bring the jury in
all right we're ready
we're ready to continue with the Richard
Baum's testimony by video
glad to see everybody made it despite
the Perpetual snowstorm that we have
outside
so thank you Mr Sykes you may proceed
okay
so uh earlier you testified that uh you
believe there's only one way this crash
could have happened which is that Miss
Paltrow hit Terry Sanderson from behind
uh if
if another expert like Irving share says
otherwise How would
that uh
how would you think of that opinion if
that was the case
well I would disagree with it
and I would like to know what the basis
of his opinion was
and that's basically the short answer
but uh
he came up with a different opinion than
maybe he considered other information
that I I may not have had in formulating
that opinion so I would certainly be
interested in knowing what the faces
of a of that type of an opinion
and um
um do you recall a defense
expert Robert Hirsch hush MD
uh yes that's the uh neurologist
and uh his report is uh
you know the actual written part is uh
less than six pages
maybe five even
and most of it is uh or much of it is
the review of his
um
the things he reviewed
is it your understanding that Dr hush
did not examine Terry Sanderson
personally correct that's my
understanding
what does that mean
to you regarding his opinions this
doctor hush
is my cell have
insisted on examining the patient
directly to cooperate the medical
records and you get more insight because
medical records are just what they are
records if you have the source in front
of you that you're able to query I find
that that is very very helpful so
um
some people or some of my professional
colleagues don't do that and I feel that
they may
be at a disadvantage in doing it that
way but my preference has always been to
examination
I'm just going to read you what his
report says uh does Dr hush
it's Dr hash actually okay yeah Dr Hesh
he says on page three the persisting
neurological symptoms Mr Sanderson
reports
since the February 2016 ski accident are
likely attributable to pre-existing
health conditions how would you respond
to that
I would disagree with that I mean even
though he does have a history of high
blood pressure
high cholesterol
I do not feel that um he had those
symptoms beforehand
and they became prevalent after
the close head injuries so you have to
you have to be able to
um
account for
that timeline if you will or that
clinical history
then on page four he says under part two
I'm not entirely convinced that Mr
Sanderson experienced a mild concussion
how would you respond to that well that
that I would I would definitely disagree
with that I mean
him
having the the
disorientation afterwards so certainly
there were
concussive symptoms noted
shortly after the event
which would Define the concussion it's
like I said the issue has always been
whether or not these symptoms are
permanent or transitory in nature
then on page bottom of page four under
number three he says uh
the persisting symptoms Mr Sanderson
attributes to the ski accident are
subjective ones
confusion memory problems objective
criteria do not establish that Mr
Sanderson experienced a permanent
neurological injury during the ski
accident how would you respond to that
well
keep in mind in this particular type of
patient
you have the objective evidence of the
witnesses the before and after Witnesses
and of course you have medical records
so that is certainly more objective
because you're getting it from
an observer so that would certainly be
objective
in nature
would the uh what about this the um
ski patroller Whitney Smith who
saw Terry Sanderson showing mild
disorientation within about 10 or 15
minutes of the crash
our data affect your response to uh
Dr Hesh
well once again that's an observer that
observed someone that disoriented that
would be an objective model
and then he says under page five Mr
sanderson's neurological function is
normal
and his records in imaging do not
provide any indication of neurological
or any indication for neurological
treatment any response to that
I would tend to defer that to his
treating positions but certainly there
is evidence in records that he had
ongoing neurological problems that need
to be addressed
to to what extent that they're being
addressed I would prefer to the
treatment position
okay next uh the next defense expert is
Stephen Edgley
were you able to review his report
yes but I don't recall who he is right
off the top of my head okay he's a board
certified with he claims with the
American Board of physician medicine and
rehabilitation him and R he's a PNR PNR
specialist
I remember him yes
he says something different than Dr Hesh
he says
compelling evidence
on page three he says Dr Edgley says
compelling evidence indicates
plaintiff's concussion was mild
and that he lost Consciousness only
momentarily if at all
how would you respond to that
well the concussion is mild I mean it
certainly would result in some
catastrophic binding like persistent
vegetative state that
you know
um I mean he was able to get to the
clinic
but the uh so I would consider it mild
as well but the loss of consciousness
certainly was present
so uh when we say mild it's is that kind
of a sometimes deceiving term for some
people in your opinion
objection leading
well
how would you uh let me rephrase
how would you describe mild when it
comes to a traumatic brain injury
can you have the question is is uh
uh can someone have profound problems
from a mild TBI
I wouldn't say profound I could say
significant problems you can have with
mild TBI depending on what the problems
are
uh but as far as he's able to take care
of his personal hygiene which I queried
him about he's able to get about he's
able to travel on these types of things
and things so
and
keep in mind he was a high functioning
individual before this he's been retired
optometrist so with a rather high IQ
so he's able to function uh pretty well
but uh certain things that he enjoyed
doing before the accident he can't do
afterwards
and this can impact him now how
significantly it does you know I defer
to his before and after witnesses to his
treaters but certainly there was a
change
um how does uh
an mtvi
uh
affect a person or what is the range of
effects can it be you said
well be significant or
well
let's back up
there are numerous classifications of
PBI
and different organizations have come
out with this based on blast on the
scale length of Amnesia these types of
things laws of Consciousness findings on
cranial Imaging
it boils down to functionality because
that's what the brain does it allows us
to function interact with our
environment and other individuals so
a mile a catastrophic I'll just start
from the works and go backwards
catastrophically means persistent
vegetative state or dead
serious you can't take care of your own
personal hygiene so you need to attended
care that would be serious moderate
you're able to take care of
your
personal hygiene
but you can't hold down a job or do
anything outside of it that that would
be modest mild
you're able to take care of your
personal hygiene but you're able to
venture outside of the Hub and interact
to a certain degree but
it's been effective now how you perceive
it as being significant or not
depends on the individual person
so you can have significant
problems with a mild TBI
but it's certainly not going to keep you
housebound and certainly not
death or persistent vegetation stable so
miles
that's what it means by Miles okay
I will tell you this anytime you have a
traumatic brain injury that is not good
and uh
how about uh or what are your opinions
about some of the other
uh experts for the defense
there's two uh
neuropsychologists one is galit
Ashkenazi and the other one is Angela
eastfold
have you had a chance to review theirs
yes and I guess they were going to
partake the treating neuropsychologist
if you will
and uh obviously they have different
opinions but
you know the level
at which they're talking about I mean
the guy has issues and keep in mind that
one of the
one of the problems that you have
with patients with PBIS
if they have the wherewithal or the
Insight that they realize that they have
lost something some type of function
is a loss and so they tend to develop
psychiatric manifestations of this loss
in the form of depression and anxiety
and if they had a previous history of
that it just makes it worse and so it's
kind of like an exacerbation of those
symptoms as well from a
what we call a non-organic standpoint so
you have to take that into consideration
and I see that there was issue taken on
both sides with regards to those
non-organic
issues but the fact Still Remains is
that
the brain
was not functioning the way it was after
the accident as it did before the
accident
and so that's where
the organic diagnosis of the mild PBI
attempted blood so keep in mind that as
humans we do carry
the
psychiatric side of things with illness
as well
what does that mean psychiatric well
we're all emotional preachers right so
we respond to
our environment in different ways some
people are more stoiced than others and
others into you know bear their souls so
if they suffer a loss of some sort it
can manifest itself
uh according to
the
DSM-5 if you will that's the
psychiatrist uh working handbook if you
will keep in mind neurologists are
boarded by the American Board of
Psychiatry and neurology and the reason
for that is that neurochemistry is so
in-depth that that permeate both
specialties
our training has a significant overlap
neurology training is two-thirds
neurology one's the third Psychiatry and
vice versa for the psychiatrist so
there's a significant overlap because
the clinical manifestations
sometimes are subtle between one
diagnosis and another
so
just in summary
uh
Patrice Anderson New York has suffered a
mild traumatic brain injury or closed
head injury in this ski crash correct
a mild TBI as a result of the closing
okay
and uh
the evidence from the
broken rib x-rays
indicate that he was hit from the back
side
or what are your opinions regarding that
he is he was hit
from the rear on the left side of the
right
and then make contact with the ground
and when someone suffers those kinds of
uh broken ribs
what manifestations would you expect to
see from those broken rib injuries
right after the uh
trauma that causes the break
chest wall pain and pain on breathing
and if it's severe enough you you would
actually have to have insurance
why don't we take a quick break for like
three minutes or and then we'll uh
probably finish up and then James can
have you if that's okay thank you well
let's let's make it about five so people
have a chance to use the bathroom if
they want to so okay okay 204.
good
Dr Bain
how is it possible for a neurologist for
example
to come to a reliable opinion in a case
such as this without an examination of
the patient
in your opinion
well obviously it depends on the
uh certainly it would be more difficult
without the uh the paging but it depends
on the uh the diagnosis that you're
considering
well how about in this case of Terry
Sanderson well you want to know if his
symptoms have persisted if you're going
to make make the opinion that his
symptoms are permanent or not are
neurological standpoint so I I would
think that it is important
but it's like I mentioned before I have
professional colleagues that don't do
that
okay in a case such as Terry Sanderson
uh how persistent do you believe his
symptoms are in your opinion
well as of
April 28 2021 they had been Precision
for five years now after that period of
time I'm not once again I'm not a
treating division of his so I can't
comment on his clinical
uh timeline after that
um
one of the defendants uh hand-picked uh
neuropsychologist Angela eastvold
testifies uh Herb in her report
discusses uh
Terry's persistent
concussive symptoms
as being better accounted for by a
history of comorbidities
risks factors like hypertension
hyper
cholesterolmia untreated obstructive
sleep apnea
the list goes on but I'm going to just
start one at a time
and ask you well for each one
um do you think any of these things I'm
going to list better account for Terry's
persistent
uh concussive symptoms
hypertension
no
hyper cholesterol meaning I assume
that's uh high cholesterol high
cholesterol hypercholesterolemia no
uh sleep apnea no
prostate cancer
erectile defunct dysfunction
no
restless leg syndrome no
migraine
no
bilateral hearing loss
chronic insomnia
no
so in your opinion none of these things
I just listed would have
account for any of the uh
problems of persistent concussive
symptoms that Terry Sanderson is
suffering
I mean he did not have these symptoms
before of the accident
that he had some of those medical
conditions
that's all I have for now thank you
thank you sir
okay that means it's my turn Dr Bain
thanks for just making time
Deport trial here
um as you know because you've done this
before the uh a big part of what I'm
gonna do is make sure I understand your
opinions and then if if there's any
point at which
you've said something that differs from
your deposition then I'm I might point
that out and I believe you have your
deposition transcript with you correct
that is correct I do okay but could we
have that the time we're beginning here
James
uh Church 213 is what I have thank you
Mountain Time
and um
so
um
you have that the transcript of the
deposition that I took of you uh years
ago correct in this case actually I
don't remember if it was multiple years
but it was it was a while
June 21
2021. that's what I asked right that's
correct okay great uh okay so I'm glad
you have that with you I have the
exhibits to that and I can pull those up
if we need them
look at that
okay so let's start though with just
some a couple quick follow-up questions
on your background and training
experience
so one of them is just has a court ever
excluded your testimony from trial
not control no I mean I had a emotional
remedy that we're going to have an
evidentiary hearing on
the case settled right after that so we
never had the evidentiary hearing
okay and that's that's all I'm aware
okay and then uh this is just a quick
question about billing we don't have to
spend much time on it I have your fee
schedule
which is uh the document that describes
what you charge uh for your work in this
case
um and you charge varying things for uh
uh an exam or a deposition records
review uh but can you give me a sense of
how much you've charged the plaintiffs
to this point
the
the uh I think I've I've only charged uh
my retainer which was four thousand
dollars a few years back now
I am charging five thousand dollars for
the uh preparation and the testimony
today so that I have now I don't know if
I received that five thousand dollars
yet my administrator would know that but
I
I would expect that I've received nine
thousand dollars
today
thank you and then what about time spent
do you know how many hours you've spent
working on the case no I I just jot that
down and I my rate changed last year so
before when I was hired on this case I
was only charging like 400 now I would
imagine I've I've spent
uh clearly 10 to 15 hours for sure on
this matter
okay
thank you
you're welcome
okay uh have you ever worked as a
biomechanics expert in snow Sports
Science
no Sports Science yes
no no one's made themselves out as a
snow Sports Science
institution that actually hired me on
something but uh no
okay I would have to say no to that
okay and speaking of such institutions
do you belong to any organizations that
do work specifically in snow Sports
Science no I'm a member of the American
Academy of Neurology the biomedical
engineer
ing society and the Society of
Automotive engineers
I see and have you ever performed
research that focuses specifically on
biomechanics as applied in snow sports
like skiing no no oh okay I don't design
schemes
right okay
um and I just want to make sure I
understand
the way you see your role in this case
at your deposition
in 2021 you told me that and I'll use
your term the main thrust of your
testimony would be your biomechanics
opinions do you remember that or
biomedical engineering opinions yes that
I I actually I feel that way now
okay great so uh the term biomechanics
let's make sure we understand it because
it's not one at least that I use all the
time you just you just clarified it when
when we're talking about your
biomechanics opinions we're talking
about biomedical engineering is that
right
biomechanics falls under biomedical
engineering okay so just get that uh
straight and it uh like I said is a very
wide range field
and people are doing all kinds of
research and all different effects of
the field so biomechanics
keep in mind that
biomechanical Engineers tend to deal
with inanimate objects for the most part
whereas biomedical engineered tend to
deal with not only inanimate objects but
also with you
right a human subject okay
um
so
so as you just said to me you see your
role as providing mainly those bio
medical engineering we the medical
records gives us the diagnosis I mean
his rib crackers have healed up I mean
we know that and but he has this
persistent concussive symptoms that we
see throughout the medical records my
job wasn't to treat and diagnose him and
come up with treatment paradigm my job
was to determine
all that happened
and uh
and I think I've pretty much put that
out with obviously the information that
I had available
to come up with my opinions
right and so I think you've already said
this earlier in your testimony today in
terms of the
um
neurological symptoms and the the
neuropsychological evaluations you're
happy to defer to the treaters uh in in
Mr sanderson's Case well they're the
ones that made the diagnosis and so I
find that after evaluating the patient
his history is consistent with medical
records from which to diagnoses were
made so I'm not going to refute
that he has a male traumatic brain
injury due to a persisting
concussive symptomatology or the fact
that he had fractured ribs in the past
that have since skilled up
I'm not going to repeat that at all I
would say that it is consistent with
that to me the main thrust was well how
did all that happen
right and in terms of what does he need
for treatment in the future or whether
his symptoms will persist in any
um
degree to the in the future you don't
have opinions about that objection
compound
I defer I'm just going to make a general
statement I defer all future Medical
Care and the cost they're uh associated
with that care who is Traders so I have
no opinions on is future Medical Care
needs nor do I have any opinions
regarding the functionality I.E what he
can and cannot do as a result
of his diagnoses seen in the medical
records which I concur
so I defer that to others
right right and how his symptoms will
continue into the future what the nature
of them will be that kind of thing that
is correct I mean I defer that to his
treaters or the overall long-term
prognosis of his symptoms so once again
I defer all of that to his careers
okay
uh another thing that I think you made
clear in your deposition to me in 2021
that I just want to make clear here
today is that you don't have any
opinions about whether anyone was skiing
unreasonably and cause big Collision
correct absolutely now there is I have
um
no comments on how people were skiing
the density of the skiers or how that
they were conducting business that day
uh the day of the accident
no right so it boils down to how
from an engineering standpoint or a
biomedical engineering standpoint how
did he develop
the symptoms that he has that's
reflected in the medical records right
so in other words you have opinions
about the mechanics of the Collision but
not who should be responsible for it I
have no liability opinions
so the answer to my question is yes that
is correct I I'm I'm not pointing the
finger I'm just pointing to Newton's
three laws of physics and the
engineering calculations uh that are
consistent that give you the
plausibility opinions that the fall and
in fact caused the clinical symptoms
that Mr Sanderson had
got it
okay and at the end of that 2021
deposition
um you told me
I've provided the opinions that I plan
to provide at trial
um you remember that yes
and and uh as I hear it today you
haven't
um provided any
um
uh new opinions
um that are in addition to what you
provided during that deposition
testimony correct that is correct I mean
uh and I I read through fortunately I
was provided my definition just two days
ago so I read through it and the last
part of it you did ask or were there any
other opinions for that and we we
covered it
okay
um and you at that time when you you
provided those opinions you'd said that
you did not feel like you were missing
any material that you needed to to come
to a confident conclusion is that right
for my opinion Zone
okay when you just consider my opinions
I have the I had the necessary data that
I needed now right
if there's some other extenuating
circumstance I.E he fell off the chair
lift before all this happened you know
20 feet to the ground
I would like to know that and so but I
have no history of that so unless there
is some significant
departure of the information that has
provided to me my opinion still stand
true today as they did back in 2021
right and in fact in the deposition you
told me that you would let me know
through acquaintance Council if you came
across new information that affected
your opinions and you did not find such
information I did that that is correct
that is correct
um
okay I think you made this clear but um
again we're talking in a sort of strange
way here to a jury that's not present
and it's hard for me to get a sense you
know are they following so I I apologize
to if I uh repeat uh some questions but
go right ahead as I understand you
believe Mr Sanderson is one of the rare
patients who experiences uh concussive
symptoms Beyond 18 months is that right
I wouldn't say rare he's in the minority
less than five percent
up all under that category so
rare in medical scent in medical terms
is less than 0.1 percent and that's
based on pharmaceutical studies so it's
really not rare but it's certainly in
the minority
okay I appreciate that clarification I
was just using it in a kind of
colloquial sense but understand
uh but that's obviously a very small
minority 95 versus five obviously is a
huge disparation
[Music]
got it okay
um and it it seems like you based this
opinion on the post-concussive syndrome
is that okay to call it that yeah
syndrome is a is a compendium of
symptoms
okay that's all that's the definition of
okay so maybe we could just say you you
base your opinion on the Persistence of
his concussive symptoms
um
as as far as it be permanent
right okay he had a mild traumatic brain
injury day one
the question becomes is it permanent or
not only time will tell
you see right and then yes the medical
records provide that timing
right and so you point to the medical
records and then testimony from family
members or friends that knew him before
and after as the evidence supporting
this post-concussive syndrome or
persisting symptoms opinion that you
have is that right and Mr Sanderson
because I saw oh correct and and your
evaluation opinion so the answer is yes
to inclusion okay
um I believe in your deposition you said
that uh you thought Mr sanderson's
narcotic medication might have
exacerbated his symptoms following the
Collision is that right narcotic uh
medications can definitely make in
layman's terms anyone a little goofy if
you will so you can certainly have
exacerbations of certain Behavioral
uh elements if you will from narcotic
use it just depends I would have to
defer that with treaters because they're
the ones that prescribe that to them and
so they would have a working knowledge
of how that medication was affected
okay
and then uh
in your deposition I think you've said
that you you did not refer to the F MRI
not MRI but fmri in any you didn't use
that in formulating your opinions at all
is that correct yeah the F the small F
in front of the MRI these functional MRI
I do not use that in my practice nor was
I trained in that element and therefore
I don't use it in my practice and I
defer the use or any opinions from that
device to others
okay thank you
um okay I want to go through uh
as
plaintiff's council did I want to go
through and just make sure I have a good
sense of
um what you reviewed to formulate your
opinions for the
the deposition that that I took um
those real quickly
um
so what what major are you going on my
sure I'm trying to I don't have it I
have kind of some notes here I don't
have the deposition transcript but I can
I can definitely put page uh 20 is where
some of this occurs and then
page 14 has a lot of it too
sure okay and then Paige or exhibit
three to your deposition uh I don't have
I don't have any human rights
yeah I'll maybe I'll pull that up
because that will make it
more simple I think that would be
helpful since I don't have
okay so when you gave your opinions to
me in that prior deposition and as you
said today those are all the opinions
that
uh you have provided uh in your
testimony
now I do have that page but if for some
reason my copy does not have an exhibit
sticker on it but
oh that's okay and that's what I read
into the uh
into the record today so that's I have
it yes great so I'm just looking at that
deposition section at the bottom and it
lists out the people whose desk who's
sorry whose testimony you had read in
comparing your opinion I understand
and I'm just gonna note a few names that
are not on that list just for clarity's
sakes so
Terry Sanderson himself was deposed over
multiple days you did not read those
transcripts correct not before that
first episode
right
um
and you did not read Gwyneth Paltrow's
deposition no that is also correct
and
um
and then uh you didn't read Eric
christiansen's the ski instructor who
was at the scene in the Collision
correct
I don't know if I had that before or
since but he was I he reported that he
wasn't an eyewitness to the event so
uh I I can't tell you with certainty
here I'm looking at uh
the deposition itself
so yeah I'm seeing if I said that or not
back then I don't recall
on page 20 I asked you they said you
haven't read anything from Eric
Christiansen and you said no I have not
okay then I had then okay so you found
it in my deposition
I don't have any direct recollection of
that deposition so I have to refer to
the transcript that's why we that's fine
that's why we take the transcripts uh
and then another name that is not listed
here is Carrie Oaks she was another ski
instructor who was at the scene I don't
see that she's listed here
so you did not read hers I I don't
recognize the name no right okay
and then you did not read Brad
paulchucks that and and he is Miss
Paltrow's husband who is also uh there
that day of the Collision no no uh and I
don't recognize that name either so I'm
okay I'm sure I did not have that
sentence
and then the same thing for the uh Miss
Paltrow's children who are Moses and
apple they were there as well you didn't
read their depositions correct no I'm
not aware of that
okay
um
patent uh
spin or read the comments Mr Sanderson
made at a press conference held about
this case correct
no I'm not aware of that
and you had not read letters Terry
Sanderson sent to Deer Valley Resort in
August 2016 the year of the Collision
correct the
and therefore you didn't compare his
various statements about the accident to
assess credibility or look for
inconsistencies that kind of thing is
that correct I did not have that
information to even the analyze
right okay
and the same thing for doctor or sorry
excuse me Mr Craig Ramon whose testimony
you did read his deposition transcript
is listed there that is correct and
and um
you referred to his him as the um
the eyewitness today correct that is
correct and that's why I was uh
indicative of his testimony that he
thought but uh
I don't have any
independent verification of that other
than what he said
right and did you compare the claims
that he made in his deposition testimony
to claims he made in a prior interview
no
okay and then I'm not aware of any prior
okay so you didn't do any
uh special evaluation of his credibility
is that right
I only had his deposition
okay
and then I I assume since they're under
oh everyone's under oath they're telling
the truth
that's that's fair
um I understand that if that's all you
had then you guys yes yeah and
you were not aware I believe at your
deposition that multiple Witnesses had
testified that Mr Sanderson had not lost
Consciousness is that correct I haven't
read any other witness uh statements
okay so you you weren't aware of those
testimonies correct no that is correct
and
and then I guess at the time of the
deposition you hadn't read any opinions
from plaintiff's acts sorry I meant to
say defendants experts is that correct
that that is absolutely correct they
were not available
okay
um
but uh
despite having not read those
um
the various things we've went through
just now you you felt confident
providing opinions because you based
those opinions primarily on your physics
application right your applications
someone speaking yes doctor please wait
for his whole question to get out you
keep cutting him off
yeah yeah I thought this question was
over time yeah and also please uh wait
for me to just insert an objection uh so
a short pause would help
right yeah and I I apologize Dr Bain
it's probably clear that I'm where I'm
going and it takes me a while to get
there so it just did uh I understand
you're gonna have to repeat that
question again now right
um let's see
oh I was saying this despite the the
fact that you had not read the various
things we've just gone over you felt
confident offering opinions about the
mechanism of the accident because of
your application of the the principles
of physics basically
physics engineering from a biomedical
standpoint and understanding the
human anatomy yes that would
that would right and the main piece of
objective evidence that you're using
there uh to apply the the principles of
physics to get your answer is the rib
images or that's the fractures that you
see in the the rib x-ray is that right
that is correct in fact I made the
comment that those weren't present I
couldn't tell you how big the actions
hurts because then there's been dealing
with the closed head injury only and
that could have occurred any number
I see
and
I I believe uh from your deposition I
saw that it's your understanding that Mr
Sanderson initially thought he had
caused the accident is that correct
something I think that I read somewhere
around there that he bought
that he may have caused the accident now
I don't know
if uh certainly that's what he was
saying but then again
you know in a state of confusion or
disorientation who knows what someone is
going to say but I did note that
and uh
uh there are a couple other uh
materials that I didn't ask you um I
didn't point out here
um that you had not read one of them was
the deposition of Michael McMahon the
medical provider who treated Mr
Sanderson in the Urgent Care on the day
of the Collision you hadn't read this
deposition is that correct that is
correct
these are things I don't believe were uh
clearly addressed in your deposition but
I wanted to clarify
um
sure in case you had opinions on these
were you aware that Mr Sanderson
testified that there was an unnamed
woman skier that he worried about
hitting just prior to the Collision
I wasn't aware of that
and were you aware that he has claimed
um that the impact of the Collision
caused him to go airborne
I think uh he may have said that but uh
I can tell you from a physics standpoint
that that did not happen I mean Airborne
in that he fell down I guess you can
technically say you're Airborne but it's
not like he was
propulsed into the air from the ground
like uh like doing a SketchUp that did
not happen
I see
um
so Mr
remote we you've given testimony today
and you did in your deposition that in
your opinion the
Force had to be from from Miss Paltrow
had to be from the left uh side from the
B from the back is that correct yeah so
it had to drive
I mean I'm not talking about directly
from the left side but it had to have a
y component to drive them to the right
side
and that's okay so it had to been from
the left there had to been a left right
component Force application to cause
this
but you're aware correct that Mr Ramon
claims that Miss Paltrow hit uh Mr
Sanderson squarely in the back
I think that's uh from what I recall but
once again at these standings of the
side they he wouldn't know exactly how
it is but keep in mind that our center
of gravity is right down the center line
of our torso
and if there's any wide component to the
right it's going to drive you to the
right and if it's enough to drive that
center of gravity out outside of your
torso you're going to fall so it may
appear
to
an observer that someone's being hit
directly from behind but in fact there
is a lycophone component to the force
application
I see
were you aware that Mr Sanderson
reported to his primary care provider a
few weeks before the Collision that he
felt like he was getting old all of a
sudden that's the quote from a medical
record
I don't recall that but
[Music]
um you don't dispute it I said I'm not
going to dispute that I mean a lot of
people his age do say that they say it
to my face in my clinic
uh
and I I don't have a medication for that
I understand I'm sure everyone wishes
you did oh well I wouldn't be here if I
did
um were you aware of Mr sanderson's
vision problems when you formulated your
opinions in this case
yes I do believe he had Vision some
vision problems and once again being hit
from behind obviously the vision is you
don't have Vision at the back of your
head but suffice it to say
like when I was going through the
different scenarios I determined that he
was struck from behind so his visual
Acuity would not come into play in that
announcement
however that visual Acuity was connected
to a 2009 event that was uh
the cause of some MRIs that he he
received or underwent
um do you recall that
states prior test uh this state's facts
and or when cranial Imaging back in 2009
uh for an evaluation
so uh now I don't know what the working
time is was that
was that they could have involved Vision
but I don't have any recollections
I see and I should stop sharing this
page but I it is because I think we're
done with it but oh there you go
I'm
oh sorry did you no no no I I recognize
all who she oh good oh good good good
okay I'm just going up to this first
part of exhibit three which is your
handwritten notes I believe from the
evaluation that you performed on Mr
Sanderson that is correct that is
correct
and here
um you know that uh
if I can find it oh
I'll look here
um
I apologize I
I can't uh
evaluate yeah I remember my notes so you
just asked me right well I was just
going to say I can't just browse them
probably as quickly as you can
um but the the first uh Point here under
the I assume this is kind of a patient
history correct yeah the pth is past
traumatic history pmh has past medical
history
got it okay and so the the past
uh
let's start with the past medical
history right okay you mentioned you
mentioned here I believe
that he had some experience with
migraines correct is this correct
um
but you don't know uh that you've had a
stroke-like event or a TIA type event
here that I can see it might be that I'm
missing it
no he was uh that would have been in his
uh patient intake form and uh let's see
what he had on that and he did Circle
the strobe and which was yeah yeah and
basically I wrote out here's that sheet
right here yeah I can find that I made
some notes to that
and basically what he described was a
homologic
layman's terms eyeball
migraine
okay and I'm trying to figure
sorry go ahead yeah and that's what that
was and I see patients for that uh
actually quite frequently and that that
does necessitate some cranial Imaging
just to make sure that you're not
dealing with the stroke but certainly he
dealt he had a there you go a
uh uh an ophthalmologic migraine versus
a retinal artery Central retinal artery
Tia
so the description
when you have a stroke you tend to lose
something so we call that negative
phenomena
a migraine is associated with positive
phenomena ieac the lights and everything
some individuals will have a neutral
phenomena and you can't tell if it's a
central retinal artery Tia or an
ophthalmologic migraine and that's why
he underwent the uh the workout
I see okay and
um this is Page just for the records
page 20 of exhibit three tier deposition
uh and this is a as you called it I
think an intake form where he's kind of
circling various medical conditions that
he's had in his history and then you put
some notes on top about it that is
correct I review that with him and I
made some uh extraneous uh remarks
besides some of the circled items on
that list okay so you were aware that in
2009 he he had had this that
neurological event that required some
evaluation by MRI and and uh other
treatment that is correct and keep in
mind a TIA
is not indicative of brain damage you
see what I'm saying it was a transient
ischemic attack
which resulted in no damage to the brain
okay and so in your opinion was the
the vision problem that that he had it's
not connected to this 2009 event
say again repeat that again yeah sorry I
could ask that more with more clarity in
your opinion
does Mr sanderson's vision problem that
he's had over the years
relate back to this 2009 workup probably
not because that was a transient event
that got his attention and he reported
it to his uh healthcare providers who
submitted him to a workup
okay so let's go back to the
um sorry to scroll like this it's kind
of busying but I just want to be quick
here I know you've got things to move to
so if we go to
um that first section that you described
as the dramatic history for Mr Sanderson
I note that there is a mention of a
closed head injury I believe that's what
c-h-i stands for that is correct
to clarify the record a little bit for
you
out you know I see these the brackets
before and after that's before the ski
accident and then after this yeah okay
so I just wanted to bring that out to
you so I did get that kind of history
from him so go ahead okay got it and uh
it looks like he had a closed head
injury at age 10 correct that is correct
that's what he reported to me okay
um
but as I recall from your deposition he
did not tell you about fall that had
occurred after the accident and that
would have I guess been put in this
after section of of this history is that
right that is correct he did not report
at fall but then again the way I asked
the question as you've been exposed to
any traumatic events requiring Medical
Care
and so if you receive medical care then
then his reporting would have been in
error but if he did not receive medical
care for that incident then he was
correct and
okay and in uh his testimony described
this fall as causing a um he hit his
head and it caused of roughly 45 minutes
uh period of loss of consciousness is
that typically something that would
require Medical Care objection soon sex
not in evidence
I would think so if someone were was
knocked out now obviously it was just
him there and he reported that I don't
then the question is how do you know it
was 45 minutes and then he may have said
well I'm okay and he didn't seek care
but it something like that if we're
Witness
I would imagine they would be dialing
9-1-1
okay so it seems like in your evaluation
of him he denied having any significant
brain related event
or treatment before the accident aside
from I guess that closed head injury in
at age 10. that's right correct that is
correct
and then he denied having any similar
events after the accident that is also
correct
okay I'll stop trying this for a second
and we may need to go back to it but um
I want to get to this set of questions I
have about your biomechanics opinions
um in particular
as he
sounds like we're moving on to another
subject so let's take a short recess
thank you
foreign
the jury's on its way back
and you want to let the lawyers know
Mr Sorensen
Wayne do you believe that your account
of the accident is the only possible
account not just that it's the most
probable but it's the only possible
account correct given the set of facts
that were given to me and the nature of
the injuries that he's sustained that
would be correct
and the basic opinions are one Mr
Sanderson was hit in the back from the
left
and to some of his rib fractures uh some
of his risks fractured on his elbow as
he hit the ground is that correct that
is correct that's correct
and
so you took that information about the
rib fractures and performed calculations
with a few assumptions is that right
like uh well the Assumption was that he
fell which we know he did so I guess
that's not an assumption
and then
um I knew his anthropomorphic
measurements which gives you the force
calculation so
uh there really wasn't much in the way
of assumptions it's basically classical
business at that point
okay well one assumption that I noted
was just for example and I'll just use
your term you said you you've
guesstimated that Miss Paltrow weighed
130 pounds for details yeah that is
correct and um
I don't want to be insulting if she
weighs more so I just said 130 pounds
and I
that was a reasonable guesstimate
obviously if she weighed any more than
that then the cat
more more and more severe if you will
okay
um
and then you also performed as you
explained to me in your deposition you
performed a calculation
that assumed that Miss Paltrow was hit
by Mr Sanderson is that right correct
that is correct and you and you ruled
that out because you would expect the
rib fracture to be in a different place
if that had occurred is that right now
and not only that but the course
application is just not enough
oh well in your deposition you said that
uh I'll just read it here it's on page
32. he said if that was enough Force to
do it which that's borderline so you
seem to acknowledge that it might be
enough I actually did the calculation
you'd expect the rib fracture to be in
the anterior chest not the posterior and
that and that is also correct the
location is really the tell hell sign
but I also did some calculations on how
fast you would have had to been going
and striking her at a dead stop and that
kind of stuff as well so uh once again
hitting her from behind is not going to
give you the
okay but I just want to make sure I
understand this part of your Depot
deposition testimony then it says if
that was enough for us miss uh Mr
Sanderson hitting Miss poucher from
behind
uh
and and then falling that way you said
that that's borderline that and as I
understood it that meant that that might
be enough Force to do it it's borderline
it might it might not be and because I
don't know how fast they were skiing
right okay that's that's helpful and
then you
um in terms of the calculations you're
you're talking about here some of the
other scenarios that you're ruling out
as I understand it
the pages you provided to us that have
the calculations yes I don't I don't
recall any of those having the
calculations that you're referring to do
those pages contain so like when you
said I did a calculation about when Mr
Sanderson hit Miss Paltrow if you assume
that scenario oh well yeah I mean that's
uh
uh he would have had to have been going
pretty fast on his skis and then again
that would have brought in the
the Assumption of how fast he was going
and I don't think anyone would give you
that number
okay so in other words if we go to these
calculations again and Exhibits
right and these calculations do not
include the ones that you're referring
to where you're ruling out certain
possibilities
yeah this is
yeah for the head I wanted to make sure
that uh it was greater than 100 Newtons
of impact Force and so I did that for
the head and then for the ribs I wanted
to make sure that we were in the
vicinity of 4 000 Newtons which we were
so I wanted to make sure that the magnet
the fourth man I mean we know what he
fell to the ground
we just wanted to know
what the magnitude of the horse
application was
in doing so and is it enough to do that
and the injured well
okay so the calculations about the other
scenarios you ruled out did you write
those down on some other Pages somewhere
else no or did you just do them in your
head yeah I mean once I have these
calculations here because I was thinking
about the different scenarios then it
became the speed issue or kinetic energy
issue and so one of the things I did not
have was the skiers
initial speeds at the time of impact
either way
I see another thing that you uh assumed
well sorry as we're here this it will be
more efficient
these calculations we haven't gone over
them and I'm not going to ask you to go
through them in detail I would certainly
no expert on these particular equations
but these are the equations you've
you've used to provide uh or to make the
conclusions that you've provided today
is that right that is correct that is
correct okay
great okay so I'll stop sharing this
again maybe we'll go back to it but one
uh thing that I did hear you say today
that seemed to
um be inconsistent with something you've
said in your deposition was that uh this
the skis you use uh said today that I
think that the skis stayed on both
skiers during the Collision but as I
understand your deposition I understand
your deposition testimony just to mean
that or to say that the skis actually
came off
do you remember that
um no I mean the skis
I mean that's just from the rotational
analysis that I did
you would expect but you just don't know
how
type the strappings are on those keys
and that's another assumption that you
would have to make and so really whether
or not the ski stayed on or not really
didn't play into the analysis
okay so I want to be fair to you so I'm
going to I'll point you to page three or
sorry 31 uh of your deposition
transcript and you say there obviously
the skis came off because of the
bindings
and I'm I'm looking it's at the bottom
page 31 right
yeah he would choose to fall down right
I mean for some reason I thought the
skis came off so and I wasn't there so I
don't know but certainly skis coming on
or off is not going to impact the
calculations on the ribs
right okay got it
um
okay I'm getting close I think to the
end of my questions here sure thank you
thank you for uh your patience with them
so another
thing I wanted to ask is about Imaging
uh
I understand it that you you did review
the actual MRI images from an October
uh MRI that that Mr Sanderson underwent
is that right that is correct
okay and you noted in those images that
there was disease associated with aging
correct oh yeah and
and he also had an injury migraine
headache so you're going to see
extraneous white matter findings and
subcortex which you do see
I also knowed the enlarged ventricles
and the atrophic changes seen
I really did not have any criticisms of
the interpreting Radiologists findings
on that study okay got it but you you
didn't review The Imaging taken in an
MRI of 2009 we already kind of mentioned
that work up correct you didn't see
those images no it did not
and then you haven't looked at Dr
Gibby's 2021 uh March 2021 so it was
done before your deposition it you not
look at those images that was the
functional MRI
and that's that's a different uh Beast
altogether so I don't interpret those
right so actually there was a functional
but there was also a straight MRI and uh
I did not see that no okay got it
okay I just wanted to make sure on what
you had reviewed Imaging wise sure
in terms of this
of this issue about whether a
neurologist
what limitations what reliability uh
um issues there might be with a
neurologist
providing opinions about a patient that
he or she is not actually evaluated
personally I wanted to ask whether you
know about the legal rules about how a
plaintiff's expert or sorry a defense
expert might be able to evaluate a
plaintiff you don't know anything about
that correct well yes uh like in the
form of compulsory medical examinations
sure yeah I do that actually quite
frequently
and um
once again when I get involved in
defense matters
I typically do not provide
any medical opinions on patients that I
have not
um uh evaluated myself personally now if
I've done the CME on them then I'm in a
position to do so but that's just been
my personal preference
over the years and certainly I get hired
to provide engineering opinions and you
don't necessarily need to see the
patient for engineering opinions because
engineering opinions are plausible in
nature and you basically you can't make
medical causation opinions from an
engineering team
okay so maybe I should ask my question
more pointedly I mean you don't have any
knowledge about uh whether there was an
opportunity for Dr an example no uh no I
I have no idea on that and I am no
as well so that would be between you
guys and
yeah okay and then
um
and you as you said you have colleagues
who I assume you respect and Trust who
who don't perform these uh
um expert roles in the same way you do
where you oh that is correct they don't
insist on an evaluation in other words
that that is correct I just tend to be
more detailed in that vernacular if you
will that's just the way I've always
been
um
covered a lot of these things all right
I'm just going through my last bit of
note sure make sure
we've gotten it all
oh there was a
thumb discussion of this um
disorientation note that Whitney Smith
the ski patroller uh put on plaintiff's
exhibit
um let's see I think it's exhibit one
yes page two do you remember that um I
do I do
I don't have that right in front of me I
don't know if you can share that
Lawrence is that something you could
share again you're talking about this
yes yeah that's correct
page two there's a section that says
what did you do and Lawrence had you
actually read it out you remember that
that is correct
would you like me to share that yeah
that would be helpful Lawrence if you
would thank you I just have to buy Bob a
Coke Slurpee
okay I you know I don't think that'll
break the bank happy to get you one Bob
that's the health food you know
um so while Lawrence is pulling that up
I'll just uh ask you
um
as I believe you've testified earlier
your opinion is that this note about
disorientation you read that to be uh
indicative of loss of consciousness is
that right disorientation or indicative
of a percussion
okay so if you go down Lawrence to the
uh
the second page there's a this yeah
right there in the middle there's this
assessment says what did you do the
assessment mild disorientation and as I
heard you earlier you you said that this
is indicative that he he lost
Consciousness but maybe I misunderstood
yeah I mean disorientation keep in mind
or uh Consciousness is volitional
interaction with your environment if
you're disoriented you don't have that
so it's really technically a
Interruption of Consciousness for that
individual you know necessarily you
don't necessarily have to have your eye
in your eyes certainly it is a symptom
of concussion
I see so as a layperson I would expect
someone like Whitney Smith to write out
loss of consciousness if there was
someone that actually completely you
know closed their eyes
yeah you don't have to have your eyes
completely closed blacked out to call it
a loss of consciousness
um
I I can't tell you the number of times
uh on a Sunday afternoon football player
would be hit in the head and he's just
standing out there not doing anything we
are we immediately know there's
something wrong and we run out there
and we say how are you doing and then he
calls me his mom and we know that that's
a lot then we bring them on to the side
and we know that that is a loss of
consciousness clearly disorientation to
whatever degree is indicative of not
having volitional Consciousness with
your environment
okay so but if we were to distinguish
that kind of disorientation from being
completely knocked out as the
conventional or colloquial term might be
you're talking about two different
things there correct well Consciousness
is consciousness keep in mind there's
different levels of consciousness
alcohol is one level disorientation is
another okay and I mean you can see that
in the boxing ring if you will yeah
right no that and that is all perfectly
clear I just want to make sure that
we're clear about what you're saying
this mild disorientation mean you're not
saying I take it that this means he was
knocked out for five minutes no no no no
I'm saying that he was knocked out
at home right okay and I I just want to
point this out because I believe it it
was read incorrectly I don't mean that
you were intending to read it
incorrectly but I just want to make it
clear at this the second part of that
section it says reassessment
disorientation lessons so you had said
he still had it but I just wanted to
note it was lesser can you see that
correct well
because of the pictures of you guys on
my screen that's blocked out lessened oh
got it I see so I see
um yeah and I I I totally agree with you
it had lessons there you go okay I see
it now right okay got it I just wanted
to make sure you saw that and sure
um if you also go
um
to this the first page if you would
Lawrence
there is a note sorry maybe a little bit
down from there Lawrence
yeah there you go so there's a section
that says possible injury do you see
that
uh
it's under the injuries yes possible
injury and
uh and you've had to move it over to the
left just a little bit because it says
other
okay right so there's there's one X on
fracture as you see there and I take it
that that means you know the rib
fractures that is correct right rip
fracture but then uh and there's one on
strain or sprain but there's not an x on
concussion do you see that
that is correct
and do you have any opinion as to why
that wouldn't be xed out there uh no I
didn't complete the form so I I don't
know why
okay and
um
I think there's I think in your
deposition testimony you I asked you
this but um I'll ask you again just to
make sure I understand your testimony on
it the uh
there's various uh claims about his uh
Mr sanderson's loss of consciousness how
long it lasted in the record did you see
that that he described his loss of
consciousness in different ways at
different times
uh I think that is possible I mean
certainly he described the law of
Consciousness but yeah I heard I think
there was three
five minutes
I mean
uh I'm sure it wasn't completely
consistent all the way through but
except for the loss of conscience
right and and even in some of the
records plaintiff's council showed you
today
um there was a
you know the early on like in this
document right after the Collision
there's no discussion of how long he had
lost Consciousness or that he had lost
uh full Consciousness but then later
there's a progress note that says uh uh
loss of consciousness for approximately
five minutes you read that earlier it's
the next day do you recall that yes I
did okay so you did know that there were
some
uh
differing reports about that loss of
consciousness correct about the time yes
right
and so in Europe I take it you don't
have any
deep specific opinion about exactly how
long he lost Consciousness or whether he
was not totally out anything like that
is that right no that is correct he just
had a lot of notches and that's it
okay
okay I think I think I'm done
[Music]
um
let me look through one more page here
stop sharing
yeah you can stop sharing Mr beuler
thank you I've been calling you Lawrence
but I don't mean to be casual you can
call me later James if I can be casual
with you maybe okay uh may we take a
short break doctor yeah I'm actually
done so we thank you very much Mr Egan
and yes so a break as well I'd say five
minutes thanks thank you coming out
Brook at the time is 3 13. okay we're
back on record the time it's 3 24 and
did you want to make your announcement
Lawrence
uh thank you Dr Bay
uh thank you sir and uh I appreciate
appreciate it very much
thank you Dr Bain thank you sir
okay let's concludes that the time is 3
25.
thank you Mr Sorensen uh Mr Sykes are
you ready for your next Witness
you may proceed
or we'll call Mark Harris
thank you
hi
do you swear that the that the testimony
you are about to give in the case now
before the court will be the truth the
whole truth and nothing but the truth
shall help you God thank you you can
have a seat
good morning sir good morning
I'm good would you would you start by
stating your full name and spelling at
all yeah it's uh Mark Stephen Harris
Mark with a k
Stephen p-h-e-n is the way it's spelled
and hereth is h-e-r
-a-t-h
thank you thank you
hey Mark I'm Peter Sorensen I haven't
had a chance to stand up before the jury
yet so I'm introducing myself to them
but also to you and okay
um why don't we start off by you telling
us a little bit about your education so
where'd you go to high school I went to
high school in Bogota Colombia
School named
and I was there because my dad was a
diplomat
and I graduated from there and then I
went to school college in Colorado
you anticipate where I was going where
what college in Colorado Western State
College in Gunnison Colorado
and what uh what degree did you attain
for me history of political science okay
and
then after that what is kind of your
work background what did you do after
college
after college uh I worked a couple odd
jobs in Denver and then I got uh
put a package in with the Navy and got
hired to fly in the Navy
so you're a Navy pilot I was a Navy
pilot for 15 years yes okay and what
what aircraft did you fly
I flew the A6 Intruder which is no
longer with us it was decommissioned
uh it's an attack airplane and I flew
the later on I transitioned to the
garden for that 16.
this isn't really relevant but what was
your favorite to fly
I left them both
are you married I am okay
and where do you live
well we bounce around a little bit
because obviously I'm here in Salt Lake
because I love to ski
but we have a Summer Place up in White
Salmon Washington or residence of
Washington
and we have a house in Tucson Arizona
so you kind of split the time between
the three places here best of three
places yes
and we're here today because we're
talking about a ski Collision involving
Terry Sanderson on February 26 2016. are
you aware of that yes I am okay
okay so let's give a little bit of
background how did you first come to
know Terry
I came to know Terry because my brother
married Shay
and that was around the 2000 I think it
was October 2004 they got married and
soon after that I
um met Terry and I'd already been coming
to Salt Lake so it was a natural things
that when my brother came to town and I
met him that way
so you are Terry sanderson's this might
get a little confusing his son-in-law's
brother that's correct okay
all right
and so how long have you known Terry
over 15 years
and over those 15 years did your how did
your relationship develop
yeah we started uh I met him because my
brother and I and one of my sisters used
to come skiing and so then we started
actually staying at Terry's because it
made sense
so that's and then
he was gracious enough to allow me to
because I used to be a storm chaser
to come and stay at his uh house
so it grew through skiing because we
used to ski together as well so that
sort of source would come in you you
have because of your occupation you
could fly in that's correct
that's a lot a nice slide how many uh
how many days roughly in that time
period that 2016 2015 time period where
you
it would depend on the on the storms and
stuff but I would say uh somewhere
between 25 to 30 days of skiing at that
point a year and how would you rank
yourself as far as your
they're fairly advanced
and uh
times you've got
you got to know Terry as well
as well so my son
who also flies in the Navy he
when he was 12 I brought him here for
what I call his powder qualification
trip
and that was about the same time that
that I'd met Terry
so soon after that we started seeing him
and I at his house
and uh
yeah so Terry knows my son he knows my
daughter and he knows my wife really
well
and what are your son and daughter calls
Terry
my son calls him Uncle Terry because my
son decided to go to the University of
Utah and so he would spend a lot of time
with Terry
so he came to know Terry too very well
so is it fair to say that Terry treated
you as family absolutely
just had a loving relation
ship yes
and as far as you know that that feeling
was Mutual yes it was
and you've already described some of the
scheme that I that you do
um I assume did you go with Terry when
he was skiing or when you had skiing did
you played
so when I knew Terry back before the
accident
um he had a meet-up group that he met
with a lot and it was primarily at Alta
if my recollection served me but I'm
more of a I ski both mountains
so some days I would ski with him some
days I wouldn't but I've skied with him
at Alta Snowbird and other places as
well
so in that time you've skied with him
did you get a chance to see his uh
skiing level yes I did and how would you
rate that
Advanced intermediate
did you ever notice him to
did you ever see him get in an accident
or have any Collision or crack I did not
describe Terry's personality a little
bit for
before the accident in that time period
of 2014. before the accident uh very
outgoing
loved a good conversation very
conversational
just really enjoyed being around people
so I mean you had the Meetup group that
he did he'd go out and go dancing
so he's very very active go to concerts
stuff like that did you ever do any of
those events with him or participate in
any of those activities I was too busy
skiing
so you found him to be intelligent
absolutely intelligent witty sharp
always interested in what you were doing
and asking questions about what was
going on in your life
is interested in you yes
were you ever present in his house when
he was having any sort of parties or
social gatherings
I wouldn't call them parties maybe like
he's a big basketball fan
March Madness really big on that in fact
I know he he has a group of uh
guys that they go to Marshall they used
to go to March Madness games
so they've traveled to go see travel to
see March Madness games and so he have
he enjoyed watching football
so you might you might have three or
four people over the house but I
wouldn't call it a party
would you so you'd watch the games with
him and just gather together
have a barbecue or something like that
right
in those times as you see Terry being
social and interacting with these
friends and people oh absolutely it was
completely social
that was one of the strong suits
roughly how many days before the
accident do you think you spent staying
in Terry sanderson's house
if you do just basic math it's got to be
similar over 50.
yeah
so you got to observe observe him from
kind of set up the sun down Sundown when
you weren't skiing absolutely
and you've got to know him pretty well I
did would you say it was a pretty close
friendship I would
did you ever worry about Terry when you
went skiing with it I did not it was
clear to me that uh
that he had been quite the athlete when
he was younger because he was
he was a very strong skier
do you ever tell you about any of his
younger Athletics he did not
but you saw him to be very capable of
anything that the mountains throw at it
yes
prior to the accident did you ever see
Terry being forgetful
no
when you guys went packing up
when you guys packed up to go skiing did
you ever see Terry forget anything that
he needed to go skiing that day I have
no recollection that but we all forget
stuff
but he could make do if he did forget
okay
nothing like that stands out to you no
it does not
let me back up just a little bit you've
got then I mentioned it kind of in
passing but what do you currently do for
employment I currently uh work for FedEx
as a pilot so you retired from the
military and now you're working that's
correct
and so you're able to to come in and
Chase
it's one of the benefits yes
you were not with Terry skiing that day
when he was I was not
mm-hmm
how did you first come to hear about the
ski Collision I actually got a call from
Terry that evening
he told me that he'd been in an accident
didn't
give any details at that point and just
was concerned about I was going to get
back from Park City
and then I didn't hear back from him so
I have no at that point I had no idea I
still don't know how he got back to who
brought him back down the mountain so he
was confused when he called you about
how he was even going to get home he had
no idea
did you offer any suggestions well I was
pretty convinced that when I was going
to get another call and uh
to come up and
you know help him out but I didn't
do you recall him asking you to be at
the ready or to to be ready to come help
him
I don't recollect the exact verbiage he
may have said I might need a ride but
you know
yeah I did I just was kind of
anticipating that might be the case was
it a long phone call or was it
relatively very short
just kind of informing you about the
accident and that he might need a ride
home that's correct
did he did you recall him telling you
anything about his injuries not not at
that point
you didn't hear again from him that day
that's correct when did you next hear
from Terry
it was the following day
and did he describe anything to you in
that phone conversation that sticks out
to you yeah he said he's gotten um
it heard a scream and got hit by behind
and um and it Fallen face forward and
gone unconscious on the snow
and then had to be removed from the
slope when it's bargain
what was your reaction when you had
heard how he had kind of characterized
things say it again please what was your
reaction to hearing how he had
characterized what had happened
well collisions are like the in my
opinion the biggest risk we take on the
mound so being hit on the mountain
doesn't surprise me at all
did this did it surprise you that he had
injuries from this
no that doesn't surprise me at all it
surprises me that um
what he said but at that point in time
was that when Paltrow hit him
I'm not gonna okay
and then that
she and whoever she was skiing was left
the scene in the accident that's what
surprised me
and why would that surprise you
now
how he knew how Terry knew that that had
happened double hearsay
overruled go ahead I think he's just
describing his memory
and why would that why would that that
bit of information surprise you
well because
um
my roommate in College's mom got hit on
the slopes and the kid tried to escape
and they chased him down in Colorado I
don't know if the law in Utah or
Colorado right now but
you don't it's like a hit and run and so
it's a serious offense and just
something you just don't do
foreign
sir so members of the jury there's no
claim in this lawsuit based on a
so-called Hit and Run
there is no claim before the jury based
on a theory of hit and run and the
witness should refrain from using that
term terminology
the term is stricken from the record
and the jury should ignore the witness's
use of that term
thank you
let's move on a little bit um
that Terry had problems with his
eyesight
yeah I was aware of you had some
problems with one eye okay did you ever
see that affected his skiing at all
negative
did you ever witness him making
decisions on what they to ski based on
his eyesight
well I think he preferred to ski on
nicer days like we all do
you know because visibility is
can be challenging for for anybody but
you never saw for instance a time where
he said I'm not going to go up today
because you know
so going back a little bit when Terry
finally did describe what happened to
you or what happened to him excuse me
to you
did he ever tell you that he lost
consciousness
you did
he ever tell you that I think you said
this already but that he was taken off
the mountain in a toboggan he did
when he spoke to you a little while
after this accident did he tell you that
he was sore that he was still
absolutely
where do you describe that pain if you
recall well he had
some broken ribs so main torso area
and did you did you see him or what
excuse me what was the next time you
actually physically saw it
that's a very good question and my
recollection it probably would have been
within two weeks of the accident okay so
not not immediately yet but no
and when you saw him next did you notice
anything physically different about
Terry
not so much physical but other than
walking slower and stuff but uh mentally
for sure okay what did you see that was
mentally different
just a slower you know trying to digest
stuff in conversation
and stuff and uh decision making
type stuff so just
two weeks or so in between the last time
you had seen him you saw noticeable
difference in his cognition his ability
to think absolutely
do you notice any other differences
well he lost his uh
some of his motivation and excitement
for
I mean he's you know recovering from a
major accidents so
he was moving slower less motivated less
excited less enthusiastic
did he just
he just feeling different at that time
too
yeah he was uh he he knew he wasn't he
didn't have his full faculties at that
point
and how did he describe those things to
you how
well he said that you know you'd start
doing something for example like us
an easy task and then just kind of stop
and go
why did I come over to this part of the
kitchen or the or the house and be so he
was was having issues with memory
and when you saw him was Carlene
Davidson there
no she was not so this was after Carlene
had left and he was having these kind of
trouble yes
after the accident has your relationship
with Terry changed
it has
um you know we had a very strong
relationship and I was actually
staying at his house for prolonged
periods
through 2015
but it just so happened that we had made
a transition for the C the 2016 season
so I was actually not staying at Terry's
at that point
so that
um
so I wasn't seeing him as much or doing
as much with him
would you still keep in contact with him
though absolutely I would you know
going from Arizona to Washington back
and forth I always stopped in the state
at this place in the Fallen spring
just to check in and keep the friendship
going right and I also go out to dinner
with them on a regular basis
and and when you checked in the next
time and we're talking now after that
two-week visit that you had seen it
following that
what changes do you see in Terry
the biggest changes I I saw is um
in conversation like I said before you
know it was a great conversationalist
and it became difficult because he his
comprehension
had gone down
you get and you get confused you know
you start talking to him and and you
thought you were talking about maybe
someone else
and then you realize that he wasn't
following the direction of the
conversation so confused comprehension
and
and then you know after a few instances
like that you could tell he was getting
frustrated with that
and so did you show little signs of
frustration
how would that manifest
you could just see it you know on it you
just kind of shake his head
and then get try to get back into the
conversation
did you ever witness that he was more
depressed
I didn't actually witness things more
depressed but I witnessed that he would
it was like a
day and night as far as before and after
the accident it wasn't going to my
knowledge he hasn't
ski I think he tried to go skiing a
couple times but he has a speed really
since the accident
I can't speak to going out dancing but
it doesn't sound like he's been nearly
as active so
but you have not skied with him since
then I have not
have you ever talked about skiing with
him
I talked to um the first year after
skiing after his accident about skiing
but um it was clear to me that that was
kind of a dead end Road at that point
just because he wasn't interested in it
or or he he wasn't mentally prepared to
ski again
you know
did he ever describe to you how you said
you think he may have gone a couple
times after the incident do you ever
described you how those times went for
him no he didn't
did you ever see uh him be more paranoid
after the accident
yes
um describe that for us well very
basically he um
visiting his house coming through on our
trips to North and back to the South all
of a sudden there were cameras in the
house
multiple cameras in the house and it was
clear that he was videotaping both
you know Visual and audio
and it was just
I found it to be unusual and
a little disturbing random from my end
so he didn't have those cameras in the
house before no
did you ever see him be
have have problems with headaches or
dizziness
I didn't I didn't witness that
do you ever say that he was having those
problems
I can't reluctant recollect that he's
ever said it to me
I think earlier you said that you felt
like his motivation had changed can you
describe what that meant to you
yeah basically it's motivation to you
know you get up in the morning and had a
hard time getting motivated to get going
and get any basic stuff done or
in his case go out and do stuff socially
I think the jury's heard testimony that
Terry was kind of a and this is my turn
but kind of a fiery guy before he was a
high energy very high energy yeah was
that the same after the accident
negative
did you ever hear and it's been brought
up a lot and it'll continue to be
brought up but did you ever hear
anything about a GoPro video of this
event
no I did not
has Terry ever said anything about that
to you he has not
so to your knowledge there's never been
a GoPro video of this event that's
correct
so just to recap
you would say that this ski accident has
greatly impacted yours and Terry's
relationship is that correct that is
correct how so
it's not enjoyable
to be around Terry like it used to be
just because because of the fact that he
he's confused a lot
and we talked about paranoia and he's
more anxious around people
and so
you can only take Terry in small doses
now
so this
is almost familial relationship you guys
had has been forever altered in your
opinion that's correct
that's all I have for you mark thank you
we have a few questions
the other lawyer may have a few oh
absolutely okay
Mr Egan
it's your honor how's it going Miss it's
herith here atheist pleased to meet you
Mr Harris pleased to meet you my name is
James Deacon I have a few questions from
the defense
um how long were the stays that you had
with Mr Sanderson prior to the accident
you described staying with him I think
50 plus times in the Years prior to the
accident usually like we're like four or
five days at a time
okay
and then on the limited interaction with
him after the accident is that right
that's correct in person
that's correct
um when you described your understanding
of the accident as you received it from
him I just want to clarify
was it your understanding that that was
his own first person understanding or
that he had received that from someone
else that was his first person
understanding of the accident
so he didn't tell you I I was told this
by somebody else he did not see what
happened
um
you use the word paranoia which uh maybe
is is not a term that
um could can be used technically perhaps
in a medical setting uh you describe
cameras and um
kind of obsessiveness about people maybe
watching him I'm trying to make a sense
of what you mean well you know
back to the paranoia I also used being
anxious around people and so it also
came out in the relationships
and I saw him
in relationships after the accident
okay so if he denied in medical records
after the accident he denied paranoia
would you be surprised
no okay would you dispute that I
wouldn't be surprised that okay done at
all
and would would you dispute if there are
medical records show that he
acknowledged taking medications prior to
the accident
for lack of motivation you wouldn't
dispute that I have no knowledge of that
okay
and do you have any knowledge of prior
history with
um a stroke-like event that caused the
need for Mr MRI scanning of the brain no
I do not what about brain Imaging
findings years before the accident that
are consistent with aging you know
anything about that no I do not what
about cancer diagnosis
I think he had
a prostate cancer okay yeah he did what
about heart palpitations or heart
trouble before the accident not aware of
that
microvascular disease
don't know about that
were you aware of aware of any
medications he was taking before the
accident I was not
osteoarthritis
nope
um knee problems
not that I'm aware of no a foot drop
a foot drop yeah are you aware of what
that is I'm not okay just as I
understand I kind of uh
malfunction of the foot such that uh
you're sort of pulling your legs
slightly no I never actually witnessed
or saw that or her and talk about it
okay
um
respiratory problems nope sleep apnea
I'm not aware of sleep apnea insomnia
no
okay
anxiety
um before the accident and I mean in the
in the sense that he was taking
medication for that condition not just
that you're telling me you're taking
medication yeah were you unaware of that
no I'm not aware okay
were you aware of any post accident
travel that he he did internationally
well he did a lot of traveling before
the accident and but I would be you know
I'm not aware of any there may have been
a trip that he made but no I can't
remember okay it sounded like you were
gonna say you'd be surprised if he
traveled after or am I right yeah
um
there's a record that the jury's heard
about
a few weeks before the accidents and
medical record where Mr Sanderson
reported to his physician that he was
getting old all of a sudden and not
doing things that he used to do
you remember him expressing any similar
sentiments prior to the accident no
because when I knew him before that
accident he was still active
and your wife is Shea correct no that's
okay Brothers your brother's wife
correct my wife is Lori yes sorry I
um
so
she I believe has described your
relationship with Mark as they're saying
you are marked with Mr Sanderson as
one-sided
one-sided have you ever heard that I've
not heard that which way was it going
supposedly uh so I'll give you a little
more maybe and then you can tell me if
if you have a similar understanding
um
they were uh was Testament that Mark was
finding out when my dad Mr Sanderson
would be gone so that he could be in the
house without my dad there no that's not
true that's not true no I visit my
business we're based on Storms okay and
then there was a sense that Mr Sanderson
was frustrated with you
because of that one-sidedness and that
uh he he thought it was not worthwhile
to have a one-sided relationship and
that was the reason you guys stopped
having a relationship does that that's
not true on my side if he felt that way
he never expressed it to me okay
I think you said that you went to the
um
home Mr Sanderson I after the accident
maybe two weeks following is that
correct well we I think we met up for
dinner oh okay so yeah did you
um have any interaction with Carlene
Davidson during that time
I had interaction with Carlene but I
couldn't say it was after the accident
okay for certain
so Mr Sanderson didn't talk about who's
caring for him in those weeks just after
the accident
I don't recollect okay
that's a good aspect of it no
I believe that's all I have thanks thank
you
Sorensen
Mr Harris do you uh her Mark do you do
you discuss medications and medical
conditions with all of your friends no I
think it's a very personal thing and I
don't think I should be discussing or
asking that kind of question with
anybody
do you ever read your friend's Medical
Records I do not
and would surprise you and I know that
there are some questions about this
one-sided relationship just barely
would it surprise you if Shea Harris
actually said
I don't know if I would call it an
estrangement I don't think Mark knows
why my dad hasn't been reaching out
towards him
my dad would be civil to Mark I believe
so it wasn't like a horrible thing that
happened between them as far as I know
he just thinks he just thinks I think my
dad has forgotten how much Mark has
really been there to help him through
all of this would that surprise you no
okay
Mr Egan anything else no all right and
is this witness under subpoena
so we can release him from the
exclusionary rule
okay you're free to go you have no
further responsibilities here appreciate
it thank you thank you
plaintiff may call their next Witness
how's the jury doing for a break
why don't we take a short break
or did you did the jury say they wanted
to break
okay we'll take a short break then and
then we'll proceed to lunch after or
we'll
stay in the courtroom until lunchtime
after that all rise for the jury
we go a little afternoon before we break
for lunch
thank you
juries are on their way
won't you plan on breaking around a
quarter afternoon for lunch
or you know give or take depending on
where you're at
true
Mr Sorensen
thank you
I swear that the testimony you are about
to give in the case now before the court
will be the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth so help you God
thank you
good morning
would you start by giving getting your
mouth I mean your body toward the
microphone position and then give your
give your full name and spell your name
please
my name is Shea s-h-a-e
middle name and maiden name Sanderson
[Music]
s-a-n-d-e-r-s-o-n last name is
pronounced like Harris with a lisp it's
herath
h-e-r-a-t-h
hi Shay hello
just as a little preliminary matter as
we're talking
just remember to say yes or no instead
of instead of nodding or it's okay yes
sir I know you're nervous yeah
so that's okay but what I say is less
important than what than what the jury
hears you say Okay so we're talking
right now but if you wouldn't mind
addressing the jury when you're asking
your questions or when you're answering
your questions excuse me that's
wonderful sounds good thank you
why don't we start since you've already
said your name by telling us where you
went to high school
and then where'd you go on to college
um I started at Utah State University in
Logan Utah
and transferred up to University of
Idaho in Moscow Idaho
okay and did you graduate from college I
did okay what was your degree
I have a bachelor's of landscape
architecture
and briefly for us uh give us after
college a little bit of your work
history
after college I took my first job in
Beaverton Oregon
which is funny because it's really close
to where I was born in Hillsboro Oregon
so I was returning back to where my
rates were
and I worked for a small family owned
business
my boss was about 72 years old
and his daughter also was my boss but he
was the most joyful man I've ever known
he made me laugh every day and he passed
away recently and he's gonna be missed
but he's with me in my heart
oh thanks I will be meeting those
do you need some too
you are one of Terry Sanders I am okay
so give us the birth order if you would
mind yes I am the eldest of three girls
and my middle sister Polly has testified
already she's three years younger than I
am
and my I call her my baby sister but
she's not a baby
her name is Jenny B and she is nine
years younger than I am and I was a mom
to her essentially
and would you guys describe would you
describe your sister relationship as a
close one
very very close relationship with my
sisters more so with Paulie because she
was only three years younger than me and
I missed out on about nine years of my
my little sister genieves growing up it
was
kind of surprising we would see each
other on vacations and in between but um
I didn't get to witness her growing up
when you went to college were you
roommates with Holly I was roommates
with Polly and
um
she had a hard time waking up in the
morning and so often I had to go into
her bedroom and shake her because her
alarm would go off for a long period of
time
um she was my best roommate
yeah and Friends
what was it like growing up with Terry
as your father
so I I really idolized my dad growing up
because he was an extrovert he was
gregarious everyone seemed to love him
um
he had this zest for life and he
he just wanted to know so much he loved
to immerse himself in learning more and
more about especially in the health
industry he would read through his
medical journals and stuff
um but he was very engaged dad he
um would always show up for our events
um and usually stay and talk with
everyone in the community afterwards for
hours and hours
so luckily it was nice I could just walk
home because otherwise I would be there
forever
um
let's see could you
okay good enough I'll keep going
otherwise it's okay it's okay
um I will tell you that things did
change later on as I grew up my parents
had a really they had a really good
marriage the first probably 10 years of
their life but then things kind of they
started drifting apart and so my dad
became more of a workaholic towards the
latter part of their marriage
um so
um that was really kind of I think we
could feel that as a family that things
weren't good between them I was grateful
to have my sister Polly and when those
things would happen but um
yeah we had a happy childhood I was
loved I was hugged
um my dad was very strict very much
um we lived in a small town so you had
to behave yourself or otherwise where'd
we get out oh he was highly demanding
yes but he set expectations he hope that
you beat him yeah that's exactly right
he um he expected a lot of us girls and
he also kept us incredibly busy you know
singing voice lessons and acting and
dancing and so my mom was the taxi
driver but she also had a full-time job
so did you have the opportunity to work
with him in his eye clinics as well I
did actually my I was so blessed because
there weren't a lot of jobs in my tiny
little town
um my dad hired me
um as a sixth grader I cleaned his
office three days a week
um and then gradually as I got older
um he would teach me more and more of
the business
um and so I would work with the ladies
and help them out and you know verify
glasses and make sure that we're the
right prescription that sort of thing
and I cleaned lots and lots of glasses
when I was a sixth grader and probably
seventh and eighth grade so you got to
know your dad from a father perspective
he would also see him interact in a
business person I did and he was amazing
so well organized he ran that um office
like a like a tight ship
um he just you know everyone had a job
to do and they did it with a smile on
their face and loving their heart and
um
and I learned a lot working with him
just about character really and I
remember him one time I was going down
the hall and he said Shea you need to
walk with purpose when you go somewhere
walk like you know where you're going
and what you're doing and I thought
that's a good way you know to live
you know I don't know we've heard I
think your sisters have your sisters
testified uh about his desire to Mentor
so did you feel that same feeling
growing up absolutely my dad was all
about trying to fill out our
um we sisters heads with as much
information as we could
um every road sign that had information
on the history we were pulling over and
reading that
um going to museums he really
um
I think he was very much about character
development you know us girls the
importance of honesty
um
yeah just being a good human being
I think that's
mostly what they have to say a little
bit
what was your dad like physically
growing up
never noticed him to be deficient in any
way
anyway my dad could do anything in fact
he tried doing a backflip on the
trampoline after I had shown him now I
could do a backflip it didn't turn out
so well but he could do almost anything
except for a backflip
how old was he at the time oh
it seems like 10 years ago 20 years ago
because this
store
yeah just to establish its relevance
I'm with your what back flipping yes
I let's see I broke my arm in third
grade
it would have been before third grade so
um
I was 10 years old so 1980s Maybe
so you moved out of the house after
college and you didn't return is that
that is correct I did come home for
Summers to work a summer job though
working in your desk clinic or was that
somewhere else um only my freshman after
my freshman year in college did I come
home and work for my dad
um the other years I was trying to get
more landscape architecture background
work experience and so it was just that
year
before the accident
and in your time you spent living in the
house and even up until 2016. do you
ever see your dad have any problems
driving a car
no
he was the ultimate multitasker and
drove a car with ease
when you say multitasker I think there
was some testimony yesterday that he
would read a book sometimes
yeah is that nerve-wracking for you uh
yeah as a child I was a little anxious
and when we would head to Montana where
the roads go forever straight sorry
um straight away he would actually have
a book in his hand while he's driving
down these straight roads and um I was I
tended to be a nervous person so I was
always a little bit probably why I got
car sickness maybe on edge when he was
driving and trying to do something else
he was never in an accident as far as I
know
um I'm sure maybe someone else has his
everything about him but I don't recall
that ever being a thing
moving forward in our timeline a little
bit closer to the time of this accident
and
20 2009 to the time of the accident did
you or are you aware of any of your
father's uh the chronic medical
conditions
um I recently found an email
well first of all let me my dad is a
really private person and also he
doesn't
ever want to be a complainer and so he
has a tendency to keep things to himself
he doesn't share
um when things are going bad I think he
just doesn't like to be around those
kind of complaining people and so he
didn't want to be that kind of person so
I really had
very little knowledge about what was
going on in my Dad's life he only would
call us if he was in a good mood so
um but that being said just recently I
did come across the letter that broke my
heart he said
um that he
before is this too much literally it was
just objection hearsay can I get a
ruling I don't know what we're doing
here so can you ask another question
let's move to the day of this
of this 2016
. how did you first hear that your
father had been in a ski Collision
I believe that I got an email that said
I'm famous
in the subject line and I was like what
are you talking about and then below
there was a link that said here is
information I may not be quoting it
exactly right
from my friend and I witness and then
there was a link below
and um that link below
um I couldn't ever look at it
um because you had to be like a Meetup
member or something
um but I I have a vague recollection of
actually calling my dad and saying can
you give me your meetup group number so
I can actually look at this and he was
able to give me that information
so I may or may not have seen what was
in that link
don't remember the day of hitting that
link and knowing what it was
ah I don't know for sure if I at what
point I looked at it
um just a little background information
I had a ski accident three weeks prior
to my dad
I had turned my ACL and my MCL I was not
sleeping very well I had my leg propped
up on a pillow with ice around my knee
and I also had a four-year-old and an
eight-year-old to take care of at the
time so my memory of what happens
happened during that period is very
foggy
um
and this has already been marked as I
think defense exhibit 111.
it's been discussed quite a bit
but
d102 is the same thing and will be a lot
clearer if you want it do you want it
well we're going to go through this just
a little bit well I I know because the
the top portion is not evidence
well we take it down and why don't you
use the exhibit that has been unless you
need for some reason to enter this one
Mr Sorensen
uh this is okay as he's doing it your
honor just the top third is not evidence
well I'd rather that the jury not be
published a document that hasn't been
entered I want to make you all aware
that you are giving out information
when we're looking on these
information private information
could you please white out
the email addresses
or would that take too long
or you could just fold over that piece
of information
thank you so much
I'm sorry tree
thank you Council
do you see that up on your screen Jay I
do
and are you the Shea hair that's right
up here I am okay
let me go through this a little bit but
I want to point out a couple things just
before we get into kind of the content
um
does this appear
email that you were talking about with
the link
that you described earlier in your
testimony
he stood a copy of it I believe so I
can't remember the time
but and I trust that more than I do my
memory seven years ago so
okay
and
who's Jenny B Sanderson she is my baby
sister we're my youngest sister okay
she's not a baby she appears to be the
first person that this email is
addressed to correct I I agree
and then we've heard from Polly yes that
is my second sister
and then we've heard what we're hearing
from you right now correct so those are
the three people that this was sent to
yes
thing going up uh we've talked a lot
about this but
what is that line right here that I'm
pointing to sorry it says I'm famous
at what cost okay
and do you recall because there's a
difference here between I am famous here
and I am famous at what cost who wrote
that at what cost I added the at what
cost
when I sent my email back
sorry I don't want to cut you off but so
after you had tried to access this link
respond to that email is that correct
I don't know at what point I
um
I don't know at what point I was able to
access or if I even did see what was
here it seemed like I would follow
through to try to see what because this
is important information but I don't
know when that happened okay and I think
you said earlier that when you tried to
access this it was a Meetup Group login
or you were required a Meetup Group
blogger yes
and I wasn't a member of Meetup so I was
unable to access that
but I knew my dad was
I want to talk because it's going to be
brought up quite a bit will you go ahead
and read what this what your note says
here for the jury dad
I cannot believe how unlucky and how
crazy this all is
I also can't believe this is all on
GoPro what are the chances
I am so glad you're okay how are you
feeling this evening love Shea okay
now Shea this is an important answer but
with that after being sent that link
how did any reference to a GoPro video
come up that you responded in the way
that you did
so we did this in an opposite order
apologies seven years is so
long for my brains
um I received a phone call and thanks to
Gwyneth Paltrow's team they were able to
put together the timeline of things and
I had forgotten that actually I got a
phone call at 6 13 PM that evening and
that then I had a conversation with my
dad about what had happened
and then then the email it came later on
in the evening
and now I can't remember the question do
you mind asking again
you you mentioned you had a phone call
with your father Yes uh how did that
instruct or have influence on this
response okay
um after my dad told me about what he
was feeling and that he could hardly
think his brain was numb
um and that he couldn't take a breath
without feeling a stabbing sensation in
his chest
and that he had rung his Bell
um
I believe he mentioned that
with this big Resort and so many people
on this green run there had to be GoPro
video
um people
overruled
um and so um
so he said
GoPro footage there just has to be
because there was this
big
um
blood curdling scream before I got hit
in the back and that means that a person
that had a helmet cam of this GoPro
would look towards the screen and catch
it all on video
and um so I thought that's brilliant you
know then we have we have
complete evidence of what happened and
who was at fault and so I kind of
assumed that maybe this was GoPro video
and and we could rest easy because we
would know what happened
but you had never he didn't show you a
GoPro video no I I've never seen GoPro
video and it does not exist as far as I
know
and now after the CML you still have not
seen anything I have not seen any GoPro
video
so it was
and I don't want to mischaracterize what
you just told the jury but it was based
on that conversation you had with your
dad that you responded in this way yes
so I don't know if during the time I was
talking to him if I was had my leg
propped up and and whether or not I was
interrupted by my four-year-old or
eight-year-old at the time but when I
hung up that phone I thought there was
GoPro video and I thought that would be
comforting for my dad
to say it's gonna be okay Dad I know you
are really hurting but we've got it on
camera
so that's I'm I believed that there was
GoPro video at the time and that's why I
said that
all right
clear this
Lawrence
I've left my water bottle next to you
could you please grab it for me
the reason that I've laid them on top of
each other here is going to be important
for the jury
so this has already been
admitted and this is the jury saw this
yesterday this is appears to be the
the
post that your dad put out
uh the day of the incident talking about
the Whitney Smith that that uh helped
him down from the mountain have you ever
seen this
Evan page two
I recognize this woman's smile and I do
remember
he had an awful day but this woman came
to his rescue she was his Angel and
taking care of him finally after a long
time of being ignored on the mountain
sustained
his last response is stricken and the
jury should disregard the last part of
the comment
you recall seeing this post I do
I do remember reading that at some point
the reason I've laid these out and gone
kind of old school here with paper
instead of the digitals we've been
showing
is for an important reason
now I'm going to zoom in here
Down Below in this pre-admitted exhibit
and I want you to look at if we can get
it to
zoom in a little bit
focus it up
okay do you see below that comments uh
what appears to be some sort of a link
are you asking me yes I see the link at
the bottom and then the photos too
from Meetup the website your dad was
posting on yeah
you see these numbers here yes okay you
see photos and then slash and some
numbers yes okay
now I want you to look
this
I want you to look and see and tell me I
mean it's a lot of numbers
but do the photos that the the numbers
at the end of that exhibit
this exhibit here
these numbers correlate or match any of
these numbers down here
okay it appears
the 261 is the first one corresponds the
first one the second one is not anything
and the last one matches up with the
exception of the last digit which is a
two instead of a zero okay
they're close is that they're very close
Okay one's right on the other is close
I'm gonna switch gears a little bit
and get off a little bit away from this
email
you've given your explanation for why
you wrote about a GoPro video is that
correct
have a question so the fact that the
numbers matched up just means that those
two are correlated
it may okay I'm not I'm not going to ask
for an opinion and I'm not a cyber
security or not even cyber security but
I'm not a cyber expert so I don't know
okay if that means anything I just think
it's an interesting coincidence for now
that those are
those are correlated yeah
now
you've given us your reasoning for why
you wrote that line about GoPro is there
anything else that you think may have
influenced while you put that in an
email
I think I've already said I think I just
wanted my dad to have peace of mind that
there was video footage out there that
was gonna show what happened
you didn't know that there was or was
not I did not know that
and also let me just state to the jury
that my dad had
a traumatic brain injury when he sent
out that email
which is why
I found out
sustained we do need to wait for a
question before we address the jury so
thank you
evidence that my dad had a brain injury
at the time yes the comment will be
stricken in the juries to disregard
let's stay on the facts
um
after the accident you have maintained
contact with your father correct I have
you noticed any big changes in your dad
my dad has
quite a few personality issues obviously
the
the injury to his brain has caused
significant damage enough to cause his
personality to change
moved to strike overruled as as to a lay
opinion under rule 701
what have you seen as far as your dad's
personality traits that have changed
my dad is very insecure he doesn't show
it but he doesn't trust his brain
anymore
is that a hard thing for him it's
incredibly hard because he used to be
able to multitask and do
all sorts of complicated tasks and now
he has a hard time just
following through one step at a time and
he used to be able to do multiple things
at a time so it's been really hard on
his personality he feels
inept
um frustrated you don't know exactly how
he feels you're right
um from his daughter's perspective
I feel that his life is exhausting
and uh
hard to hear
have you noticed things about his
ability excuse me I mean in artfully
asked have you noticed any differences
in his ability to listen
oh
my dad used to be a really good listener
um but since the accident
his brain has to work so hard at what
he's gonna say next that his ears just
shut down and he's goes inside he's
internal and he may be standing in front
of you but he is not he's not there he's
gone inside coming up with the argument
or the next thing he's going to say and
so his listening abilities have really
been hampered by this and brain injury
now you told in your deposition you told
us a story about the van door would you
please share that story with the jury
okay
um first thing my van door from the time
I bought it
um it was a brand new door um van at
this time but it always has a problem
um I own a Honda Odyssey and if you know
them the doors don't swing open like
this they actually go parallel with the
body of the car
and so
for what time frame we're talking about
she did say after when did you buy the
car
um my daughter was born in 2000 and let
me
2012.
so this happens
um after 2012. this happened when my
oldest was 11 so it's been about six
years ago
it was this accident after the accident
yeah
thank you
um
so this van door because children
sometimes ride in it has an optical
sensor that will back the door the door
will not close automatically
mechanically if it senses there is
something in the way and that's to
prevent a kid's arm or somebody's
something getting caught in the door
but my van door has had a problem with
it thinking that there's something there
when there isn't
um and there's a really easy fix
um you just go to the driver's side and
there's the manual toggle on the
dashboard where you turn off the
electronics part and you can manually
shut the door
that should be enough background
information
um we've my dad and I have picked up my
daughters from school and we're going to
the dance shop to get some ballet shoes
for my daughter Tia who is about 11
years old and that means her sister is
roughly
six six years old
so we go into the car oh my dad happens
to be in the passenger seat as I'm
driving the van to the Dance Shop and we
pull up to a parallel parking position
right in front of the store
and because my six-year-old is in a
booster and there's oncoming traffic I'm
paying close attention to get her out
that's not important what's important is
as we came out I noticed that the van
door on the opposite side
um so on the curbside had been left open
no one had shut the door and I was it's
downtown Spokane so I was a little
concerned that we had been robbed or
something but I took a look and
everything was where it was supposed to
be
and so um
my older daughter Tia jumped in Grandpa
Terry's right there with her
um to buckle herself in and she goes to
push the button and and meanwhile I'm
actually with my six-year-old trying to
get her into her car seat
um so she pushes the button and it does
this funky thing which is it backs off
and refuses to close
well Tia's known that there's an easy
fix for this you just have to hit the
button and
um my dad's like oh I could do it I
didn't know exactly what was going on at
the time I could see through and I could
hear an heated argument and anchor and
frustration and my little daughters like
trying to explain to Grandma Terry no my
mom can fix this and my dad's like I
know what to do I can get a 10 myself
I'm the adult here you're just a little
kid you don't know anything and he was
really laying laying it down hard on her
I was
um anyway what happened is with all this
commotion going on I figure out what the
problem is and I look over at my dad as
he is with all of his might like a
football player trying to push one of
those heavy padded things
pushing that door closed and it is like
barely moving barely moving he and he
finally gets it to about
two inches closed
and I was like oh and I switched it to
manual so he was able to close it and
he's like see I told you I could do it
and he was just belittling my little
sister or my little sister my um my Tia
my oldest daughter
and just going you know I know I know
what to do I'm the adult here and just
being so awful to her and it's actually
damaged his relationship with her
because he was so awful to her and
I got in the front door
and closed the door and I looked back
looked back at my little my little
daughter and she's just red cheeked and
her tears are screaming down her eyes
and
Steve it's just
so belittled and made to feel like she's
stupid and and um I just put this didn't
have to happen if he just listened to
her if you just listened to her and say
mom can fix this and she was like I knew
he was gonna break the door mom I knew
he was gonna break the door and he
didn't flippily but it was so awful
awful experience and I have never known
my dad to raise his voice or scream or
belittle or do those sorts of things it
was just a very uncharacteristic of him
and how has Tia told you how she feels
about that
relationship she doesn't she does not
like my dad she doesn't like him
oh
have you noticed any other times where
you've seen your dad since
this 2016. have you seen any other times
where your dad's raised his voice and
anger like he was against his
granddaughter that was actually the
worst I mean and I will say that my dad
and I see eye to eye a lot
um so there's not been a lot for us to
argue or fight about so
I know my sister Polly alluded to an
interaction that he she witnessed with
my baby sister Jenny my youngest sister
Jenny
um in which he got right in her face and
set a few like screened a few of you at
her which again I he doesn't talk like
that and he doesn't
raise his voice sunscreen that was not
the old Terry that I knew as a dad I had
never seen that growing up no not at all
he was so patient
have you ever have you seen or known
your dad well I mean
since you brought up your sister Jenny
yes in this incident we heard about the
Journey about yesterday
um
you know the family Dynamics in your
family yes I do it's complicated
my family is there's people that are
maybe closer to one another
and for their ways that are that or is
that your perception
I'm sorry I missed the last part of
yours
every family there's relationships that
are closer maybe some that are further
away is that your perception yes
and would you how would you characterize
your fathers from your own opinion your
father's in Jenny's relationship
um before the accident or after the
accident
I say before and then we'll ask after
okay
um
my sister Jenny B is neurotypical and
she
really reference sure bar yeah sure
thank you
all right this appears to be a good time
to take our lunch recess so we will do
that at this time returning at 1 30.
Miss Hurst if you could just remain here
for just a moment thank you
all right so miss Hearth um
there are a lot of there's a lot of
medical experts in this case and you're
not one of them
and so
um
we want to be careful that your
testimony limits itself to what you
observed okay and maybe opinions that
you formed based on those observations
okay but what we don't want you to
testify to is a medical diagnosis
of Jenny a mental health diagnosis of
Jenny or I guess describe her
describe what you've seen with her in
terms of a medical diagnosis or medical
terminology does that make sense we
don't
is that what you just said
I think I'm a little yes we do not we do
not we do not want you to be explaining
what you've observed with Jenny in terms
of a mental health diagnosis like a
person with this mental health diagnosis
is I mean I see Jenny doing these things
that are like a person with this mental
diagnosis okay but rather just what did
you see what do you notice about her
okay what what have you observed and and
what um and you're certainly I mean is
the word was the key word that you
didn't want to hear was the
neurodiversity I think that probably
triggered triggered the concern because
that's more of a medical terminology I'm
not sure okay it doesn't sound like an
everyday observation though you're right
okay I understand I mean I could I could
say I could see you translating I mean
if you made an observation about uh
about Jenny and you're using that term
to describe that observation I could see
you Translating that into everyday words
okay as to what you saw and what you
observed okay but in terms of using
um a medical sounding name I guess or
label okay that's what we're that's what
we need you to avoid okay
Council okay with that instruction
yes and I just want to make one other
statement that's separate from this just
a minute then well I don't want to
conflate the two are you okay with that
instruction to the witness okay
your honorable making copies my staff
has advised me that somehow with the
help of it
I'm not even going to misspeak except
someone has accessed that link
that we've been trying to yeah
well right I'm going to hand out copies
why don't we why don't we do this in
Chambers
and if you need to put something on the
record we can do that after that sure
and I'm not even prepared to I've just
been advised that that link has been
accessed not a GoPro link but the
the the actual link it's just that this
witness is under the exclusionary rule
and I'd rather not discuss it in front
of this witness fair enough should we
meet at
when do you want to meet 115 would that
be enough time sure in Chambers yeah
let's start in Chambers if you could
make me a copy yeah we're making some
copies I just got handed it okay thank
you
and thank you you're welcome to go take
lunch or whatever but you're still under
the exclusionary rule as a witness not
to discuss the case with other Witnesses
thank you thank you so much
foreign
thank you
is providing
yes Miss Harris you can come take your
seat the jury's on their way
sometimes someone's run into the
bathroom like Steve Owens I don't think
we should start without him or start
without me let me just be a 30-second
delay but I just hate to become Runner
man this time that I do start without
all the lawyers here I'm I'm getting an
okay from the tables like it's okay it's
okay to begin so I guess let let your
table know don't start without me
if you have to leave
absolutely at any time yeah just turn to
me and
do that sure
let them know
thank you
Mr Sorensen
a shade before we broke for lunch
um we were talking a little bit about
your family about some
do you remember that questioning I
forget the question now but I remember
we were talking about family just to
bring us all back kind of what we were
talking about
um
have you ever observed and I'm not going
to ask you for any sort of medical
opinion or any expert opinion I just
want you to tell us what you have
personally observed in your family
and the family Dynamics between your
father and Jenny
what are those
I think they're they have a hard time
communicating with one another
um I think because of my dad's traumatic
brain injury and I'm speaking of
after the accident before they also
to the accident which are medical
opinions so if we could say factual
sustained
also as a as a demarcation point in time
and the witness can't as well okay
so do you want to ask a question please
so after the accident
what have you observed about your father
and genius relationship again not any
sort of expert opinion or but just from
a sister's perspective what have you
witnessed
I have seen that my dad and my sister
do not get along
um they have a hard time communicating
to one another
she thinks very differently than you are
or I may think
and she really
comes from the heart and
also my dad is a bit of a fixer and so
he wants to help Jenny
and Jenny doesn't believe she's broken
and I don't believe she's broken either
she just sees the world a different way
but that that causes a lot of problems
with their relationship and also I think
after the accident my dad has a hard
time Hearing in that
he is always thinking about what he's
going to say next and so oftentimes he
doesn't hear the other side of the story
and a person feels like they are not
being listened to
in that case and that is a big
frustration not just with Jenny but with
other
people in the family
thank you and
you mentioned the way that Jenny sees
the world
have you ever had a situation where the
two of you have viewed an event
and your perceptions of that same event
a shared event was totally different
there was a time when the three sisters
got together for a little gathering at
my mom's house when my mom wasn't there
extent or post accident in the time
frame
I don't have a clear recollection
Counsel on what
what the exact it's probably around the
time of the accident but it's we're
talking about my sister Jenny and not my
dad
this story doesn't involve my dad
whatsoever at this at this
remember I have
um
there was a time when the three of us
girls were sitting on my mom's bed down
stairs and
for some reason Jenny B was very upset
with Paulie and she was very angry and
she was yelling at Paulie and I could
not
understand where Jenny was coming from I
didn't understand
why she was so angry with Polly because
she's really good friends with Paulie
and she was tearing Polly down and I
thought where where is this coming from
I do not understand
why you're so upset and
you know frustrated of her and
I just it felt awful because
I didn't I kind of looked over at Jenny
and she had kind of a glazed over look
in her eye eyes and I was like
something is really different
I I can't put a finger on it but
something is really different with the
way that she's experiencing this right
now and it I'm sure that's her Truth at
the time but it didn't feel like
my sister Polly deserved to be treated
like that it was really hard
thank you for sharing that
I can I phone a friend
no no
you can bring I think we can do that on
cross-examination she already said it
was around the time of the incident
I'm going to move on a little bit okay
obviously the last a little bit of
questioning here for you
um
you mentioned that your your father was
very organized before he ran uh clinics
and you watched what he did while he was
running those clinics yes I did have
comparing that time before the accident
to how he is now today and his
multitasking how have you seen
differences
huge amounts of differences there is no
way he could ever run an office right
now under his current situation
um there's just too many moving balls
and he has a hard time just
you know getting from point A to point B
um he tends to get distracted and I
think his mind his thoughts are like a
pinball machine being
from one end to the other
and there's no Rhyme or Reason for it so
he would never be able to do that I
think he's incredibly knowledgeable
but
he's not able to
complete a task from the beginning to
end he gets distracted
um I don't know how he's how he how he
survives actually
um so
before her testimony yesterday
um have you and Paulie ever discussed
the changes in your father that you both
have observed
after the accident
let me make sure I understand your
question you're wondering if Paulie and
I have ever talked about
things that we've talked or think the
differences that we've seen in my dad
before and after is that correct okay I
just want to make sure I understood so
yes of course we're sisters and we're in
this together and
um
we want to find help for him and we also
need to be compassionate and
understanding about what he's gone
through
um and also realize that when bad things
happen there's a reason for it that this
is not my dad this is an alternate
version of my dad
and so if she expressed things to the
jury yesterday uh and you obviously
don't know exactly what she said no but
would you find that you tend to agree
with her assessment of how your father
is now hi
sustained as to relevant
we're going to take a minute to get set
up is that okay
okay
you mentioned uh he needs to be your dad
needs to be dealt with with compassion
did you say that
that my dad needs compassion I think
every human being needs compassion all
right Mike you understand my client says
your dad plowed into her back
I did hear that
do you agree that if she's been falsely
accused she deserves the jury's
compassion
kitchen Automotive stained
help me out
it
are you saying
your dad's
everything about your dad's personality
was good before the ski accident
and everything about your dad's
personality was bad after
yes or no
I am not saying that
so let's splice that in half now
there were problems with your dad's
mental health prior to the ski Collision
do you agree I don't know that
all right there were there were defects
in his personality prior to the skeet
Collision do you agree
I do not know that all right so
I am trying to sort of reconcile these
answers so I heard you saying you're not
saying your dad's personality everything
about him
was perfect before true
could you restate that question it was
confusing it is confusing sorry
I feel like the wet blanket in your
family exposing uh unpleasant trees
because your family is painting an
unfavorably
uh positive view of your dad before the
accident
that's the preface
overruled do you understand
um
why I would do that
I I'm not you and I I don't I can't be
in your mind and in your situation so I
don't
I don't know your perspective do you
agree though if if we're saying the ski
accident utterly changed his life you're
saying that aren't you
utterly changed his life are you saying
that yes or no
I can't answer that all right
all right is it fair in your mind at
least to look at your dad
before versus after the ski accident
like in terms of not a question I'm
sorry is it fair
like on anger on emotions on
relationships on all these things you've
been saying are different do you agree
that we ought to at least look at how
things were right before the ski
collision and then talk about what they
are now
that's a portion of the time yes okay
so those I'm trying to do that in my
next hour or two I'm just letting you
know
do you understand the concept that if
someone is struggling
from uh
26 chronic medical conditions that it
may actually impact their Mental Health
I don't and do I understand that yes not
necessarily okay do you agree that it
might
it depends
I mean this person gets a hangnail a lot
and also I don't I don't have his
medical records I don't
I don't know anything about his medical
records unless he's shared them with me
which he is a very private man this is a
tough spot for you to be in do you agree
this is unpleasant for you
first place I would choose to be right
now
I mean you love your dad you want him to
stand by him and support him is that
fair I do
even still when you heard that he was
demanding three million dollars you were
shocked by that number do you agree
those are your words not mine they are
your words in your deposition do you
recall this
shocked I was shocked if my deposition
said it then it must have been said did
you did you say it
dear deposition
preparation for today
today I have I have not committed it to
memory
do you remember do you remember a lot of
questions about
uh that you thought it was like seemed
like way too much money
those were not my words all right all
right I mean if you want to pull that up
those words
in my deposition I would defer to you
and to the deposition
page 44. that's a received exhibit right
I don't know
page what
it's exhibit 111 page 44. second
received
hasn't has not been received I moved for
its admission
any objection
s
how do you want to do it I've I've got a
Terry I can explain or we can come to
the bench
if
I mean is it relevant
I think highly all right well we'll go
ahead and proceed if that's the
objection and I expect the relevance to
be shown your binder can you turn to uh
can I come do you have a defense binder
there
is conditionally received upon showing
relevance
let me show you this document okay
have you seen this document before do
you recognize it
I have not seen this did your dad were
you Facebook friends with your dad
I
yeah and were you on February 1 2016
just weeks before this accident
um I don't recall when we became friends
on Facebook
you don't you were there times you
weren't friends with your dad on
Facebook I just don't know at what point
in our life together I became friends
with him on Facebook five years ago he
says he's writing to his daughters
do you see that the second note down I'm
sorry to break it to you in such an
impersonal way darling daughters do you
see that he's talking to you yes I see
that in the Facebook post okay your
honor uh and Terry Sanderson and his
deposition
identified this document and said it is
in fact genuine so I've moved for
admission
defense exhibit 111 page 44. true it's
been received thank you
James could you bring that up
take no no pleasure in finding these
defects in Terry and your dad prior to
the injury
I'm sorry could you repeat that do you
understand I take no pleasure in finding
defects in your dad's mental health
prior to this injury okay
okay take a look at that document James
could you bring that up
and maybe just do the first top half
James
your dad recognized this that he posted
this as uh he did and this is the first
time I've seen it all right that I can
remember and that's a straight jacket
and does that sound like your dad's
sense of humor
poking fun at himself I suppose and
mental health like that he's in a
straight jacket
do you does that sound like your dad's
humor
my dad has different kinds of humor
humor I don't know that it does fit him
and then he he did a little note to the
daughters here
Terry Sanderson I'm sorry to break it to
you in such an impersonal way darling
daughters do you believe you received
that I don't recall ever seeing this
post I
um was a busy mom a four and an
eight-year-old and I did not really
check into Facebook a whole lot all
right we can
so
um
I think maybe the best way to do this is
comment on things
Jenny said and ask you if you also
observe that okay okay
foreign
he seeks attention this is our all
before the accident do you agree that
your dad was a seeker of attention
before this accident he liked attention
affection so if chosen between having a
hug and not having a hug
sorry he'd love attention I think I
didn't enunciate that very well okay
attention not affection so he seeks
attention he likes attention
do you agree or disagree and then I'm
going to move on regardless of what you
say okay
sometimes do you think the notoriety of
this case would make him makes him feel
powerful
I'm not using the deposition overruled
could you ask yeah do you agree with
this idea that the notoriety of this
lawsuit
makes him feel powerful
I would say no to that that he suffered
from anger issues before the ski
accident disagree that he assaulted a
man
literally punched a man in the face or
something to that extent yes sir that's
true or it's not true
that's not true
why would Jenny tell me that why would
Jenny tell you that yeah
she may have gotten wrong information
your dad thought someone was having an
affair with your mother
and went and punched him in the face
punched him I guess I don't maybe I'm
assuming the face you've never heard
this before
yes or no
it's a pretty egregious allegation
have you ever heard it before
this is your own mom we're talking about
I know so yes or no I've heard it before
I've never heard it before
I've never heard it before all right
it may have happened and you just don't
know
I was not there at the time this is not
something that was a family something we
talked about around the family dinner
table okay because you're you're
reflecting I'm gonna ask did your mom
have an affair on your dad
well I'm trying to plant the foundation
here if I don't I don't know if my
the objection was to stay okay I'm gonna
flip the question and see what the judge
says did your dad have an affair on your
mother
when they were married
just move on Council thanks
okay do you agree with this statement
um that your dad would push the
boundaries of of speed when he drove
prior to the ski accident
Define push the boundaries he was speed
he would frequently exceed the speed
limit
overruled go ahead
I'm trying to ask him simple questions
so we could you please state that the
question did your dad speed a lot
in the car
no he did not speed a lot all right
let's let's let's this will help me too
um when did you leave home at what age
I left for college at age 18. all right
and um and you moved out of state or was
that in the same state I moved to Utah
so I'm out of state from Idaho to Utah
and how many years was Jenny
at home with your parents after you left
that's a great question my sister was
nine when I left and so she was there
from age nine to nine to 18. all right
and were you close to her during those
nine years
I was closer to Paulie
but
from age zero to nine I really treated
her like she was my own human baby so
yes I was close during those first nine
years
the last nine though oh from when I went
away to college I'm wondering if you
were close to Jenny during that time
I would say our connection
diminished because of my distance and
only seeing her during vacations
and that's when your parents marriage
again I take no pleasure in this but you
have a first
sounds like the first half of your
parents marriage was pretty good and the
second half was pretty bad is that fair
I would agree we had good days and bad
days but that was a good generalization
all right and Jenny was there during the
bad part
and you were not that I think it would
be harder to be in Jenny's shoes than my
own
so my question just to be clear is Jenny
was there during those hard years and
you were not true
I can't say that for certain because I
wasn't in her shoes I wasn't
experiencing what she was experiencing
did you ever observe your dad being
domineering prior to the ski incident
no
Jenny describes your dad as being
domineering before the ski accident do
you disagree
that was her truth
so what's the answer
I disagree or I don't I don't agree
I can't speak for my sister okay
uh was he ever emotionally or verbally
abusive to you prior to the ski
Collision no and after
yes or no
no okay
okay and then uh
Jenny describes your uh
emotional and verbal abuse to her prior
to the ski incident
you don't dispute that do you
could you rephrase that question sure
Jenny describes
your dad being emotionally and verbally
abusive to her prior to the ski
collision and I'm wondering
you do not dispute that do you
explain
if you have information that would tell
me that's false I want to hear it
I guess I'm not following your question
I'm really sorry
I'm going to say a statement and you
tell me uh I know that's true
I don't uh
my staff is telling me Jenny never used
the word punch she used assaulted so
it's not good thank you for the
clarification
if I asked you the same questions about
assault versus punch would your answers
be the same
I can't recall the question right now
because I'm currently answering this
question in front of me so thank you do
you believe your dad was hyper focused
on success prior to the ski Collision
no
okay do you believe that he was
controlling of Jenny
in an in an unhealthy way no
he was constantly overstepping
boundaries
that she set for to protect our Mental
Health
do you have any reason to doubt that
sustained the way it's phrased
do you agree that even prior to the ski
incident you would keep your father at a
distance
to protect yourself
me personally
yes no emotionally protectors no okay so
let me let's be clear After High School
each of the daughters moved out of state
is that fair
and
when I graduated from high school I
moved to Utah
and I believe my sister was a junior in
high school when she took a job as a
page at the White House in the White
House
in Boise Idaho
so
I'm not certain on this but I believe
Paulie
left when she was 17 to go to Boise out
of state no she wasn't how about let's
say the one year before the speed
Collision all the girls were out of
state
I should say women all the daughters
were lived out of state from your dad
that one year prior yes we all were
living
I heard you say he was a very good uh
multi-tasker when you lived with them
true
he was excellent and how many years ago
was that
well
I have to do count on my fingers sorry
sure
30.
34 years if my brain math is working
so 34 years ago you observed that your
dad was really organized and ran a very
successful
Optometry practice in Soda Springs Idaho
is that all true yes good job
remembering all that
it's hard
all right
um
he was not at the time of the ski
Collision
running
a successful Optometry practice is that
true
that is correct all right and in fact he
had retired many years earlier
well you tell me how many years
I don't recall exactly when
probably I'm not certain on the date so
I can't tell you but it feels like he's
maybe been on the practice for 10 years
right
right to kind of 2010-ish or there's
after it sounds about right you can talk
to my dad and part of the reason he
retired was because he lost Vision in
one eye do you agree
no okay he do you would you be surprised
if he told me that in his deposition
would I be surprised yeah I awesome all
right
all right I do recall him being in a
major
dispute with his business partner when
he left
his Optometry practice
okay
your honor
um
I'll try again
are you aware
one thing you've said is that your dad's
relationships with others have worsened
since the ski Collision is that true
for the most part yes so I'm I'm going
back and asking about some of his
relationships prior to the ski Collision
you with me I'm following so uh do you
recall he he was in a dispute
with one of his business partners at the
at the time he left
Soda Springs Idaho
I didn't know specifics I just knew
that things did not go as planned and
now as promised so I didn't ask for
specifics I just how about generally he
he was in it
yeah so I'm not saying I don't know
specifically or I I just want to know at
all do you know generally that he was in
a dispute with his business partner when
he left Soda Springs Idaho no I didn't
know that person all right why did you
say not specifically so tell me what you
know generally
I don't know enough about what was
happening to make
any sort of judgment tell me what you
know
that
so I need to answer yes okay
um so could you restate that question
I don't know if I can I said what do you
know
what do you know about a business
dispute with your dad I didn't know it
was a business dispute I knew my dad was
having troubles
with Mr Brown and I didn't know much
more than that jury Cauley actually
wrote a letter to the letter to the
editor in the Idaho Soda Springs Idaho
newspaper do you recall anything in that
regard no I did not
overruled
have you this trials now in day four it
seems like three weeks but it's four
days uh have you watched any of it
comment
uh have you ever read your sister's
depositions I apologize if I've asked
you this before no
are you staying with your dad literally
like last night tonight
he is running a VRBO yes
yeah staying with him
he's got great reviews five star reviews
are you saying he personally or the
place you're renting
um I just I'm trying to be funny and
it's not coming across being funny I'm
staying with my dad he's letting me stay
there no problem
all right the GoPro email we're getting
sick of what looking at it so I'm not
going to pull it out you're right
but uh
your understanding after talking to your
dad can I just make it clear that that
whole VRBO thing five-star reviews that
was all just a joke but I'm under oath
and he is not actually
after the record that that's not
happening and I apologize okay
humor and especially dry humor doesn't
come across in the
on the transcript very well I know I
understand that that's
what is it fair to say that after your
call with your dad on the date of the
incident
you understood that there was a GoPro
video
that was my understanding
because that's what I wrote down in the
email
and you also wrote I'm so glad you're
okay did you write that I did write that
all right so after talking to your dad
just uh
I think the incident was just before
noon and your email is like 9 30 at
night does that sound right I think the
phone call came through at 6 13. right
and I only know this because of the
deposition and then the email I think
came through at eight o'clock or so at
night his dad and yours maybe 9 30. okay
I think we're on the same page so when
he called you about six hours after the
Collision
your understanding was
he's all right
is that fair
what I was trying to get across can you
say yes or no and then explain
okay
um
can you ask the question again sure at
about six hours after the Collision
you talk to your dad true true and then
your impression was
he's okay
I didn't know enough at that
juncture to know what was wrong with him
so yes or no your impression was
I'm glad you're okay
that he's okay
I'm glad you're alive
no it doesn't say that though it doesn't
say I'm glad you're alive all right I'm
going to try one more of it to say I'm
glad you didn't die Dad I'm gonna try
one I was trying to lift his spirits
okay we're not allowed to argue and I
don't
want it so I'll let me just ask a
question
um I assume at 6 p.m six hours or so
after the Collision one of your first
questions is are you okay
and he said yes do you agree
no he did not say yes I'm okay all right
I'm sure you asked that question right
are you okay
and in the email I did no now I'm
talking about the call at 6 pm
I do not recall what I said seven years
ago right but isn't this like I I was in
a ski Collision aren't isn't your very
very first question like are you okay
gosh what happened right
are you with me
one of your very first questions is are
you all right isn't that true
I may have asked him that question
and he said I really got my bell rum
I can't think straight and it hurts my
when I breathe
I get a stabbing sensation in my ribs
I don't want to be hyper technical this
is why people don't like lawyers but I
think earlier you said
I rung My Bell
is that what he said
I rung My Bell I really had my bell run
wrong I really had my
sat in just
now do you want to should we pull up
your deposition where you say I'm
shocked
I was shocked to hear that he's asking
for three million dollars because I
thought it seemed like a lot of money
do should we pull that up or are you
going to concede that statement
if it's in the deposition and I said it
then I trust you well
that's nice of you thank you I accept
your trust but you I I can't testify so
if you dispute it we're going to pull it
up okay you don't dispute it we'll we'll
move on let's move on because I trust
that what you have in the deposition is
what I said
all right
separate from the skeet Collision
everything did you ever think to
yourself all right dad's going to get
older and then he's going to need more
help
so throw out the whole ski Collision
that as Dad gets older he's going to
need more help
overruled
did I ever think about it yeah my dad
prior to the accident is very young and
agile and active and I just never
thought about
what I didn't think that far in the
future
to know about
I guess it's inevitable that we all get
old so I have a 102 year old grandmother
that just went to the rest home
um but at that point in time I had never
thought about
my dad's you know what will happen in
the future for my dad I just thought he
would live forever for instance well
that's not a healthy thought you're
right it could be disappointing in the
end
it's always going to be disappointing if
you think my dad's never gonna die isn't
that true setting myself up for failure
is the 102 year old by the way is that
on your mom's side that is yeah
she's my Native American link
now your dad had two unhappy marriages
that that ended unhappily ended in
divorce do you agree
I can't agree to that
not the way you stated the whole
question all right
did he did he did have two divorces
well uh
do you know any event where actually
police were called with the second
marriage do you know anything about that
no I do not
are you getting your facts straight
up facts and I have to have some basis
to ask that I know but but let me keep
going okay
would your would your dad send you
emails you don't care about my side of
the family did he ever send you those
I've seen that email come through
uh would it surprise you if Paulie felt
like he was not fit to drive even before
the ski Collision
would it surprise me
rephrase that again would it surprise
you if Paulie felt like your dad was
actually really scary to drive with
Polly's shoes okay you described I'd
speak for her
were you ever personally present where
he's driving
70 miles an hour while reading a book
a long time ago on a Montana straight
highway
yes I was
and that made you nervous as a kid it
did but he never had an accident
as far as I know
your sister yesterday said something to
the fact like
dad took wrists with skiing you know
anything about
prior to this game
that he was
took risks
I don't agree that he took risks when he
was skiing he was very careful
he had been in a collision before are
you familiar with that
what kind of collision yeah let me back
that out did he injure his knee in a ski
accident
I I know he hasn't injured me I did not
know how it happened all right how about
throw out the knee do you know of your
dad ever uh
having a ski accident in which he was he
hurt himself
I do not recall my dad hurting himself
in a ski accident and I want to be clear
that um
I don't I don't know of a skeet
Collision where he collided with someone
else so I'm just talking about him
did he fall down on the ski run and hurt
himself
not that I know of all right
all right now multitasking while driving
for instance driving on an interstate
freeway while reading that's not good
multitasking right that's bad
multitasking I would agree completely
yeah
and as people get older
it's not uncommon is it for them to need
to focus more on an activity instead of
multitasking
think it's just general common sense
overruled
sure do you agree that just as people
get older they might get less good at
multitasking and have to focus a little
bit more attention on doing one thing
it seems like a good practice it's a
good practice probably for all of us
isn't it amen okay
there's been some talk about your dad
after the ski Collision
knocking somehow
falling and being knocked out for 45
minutes do you know anything about such
an event
um can you rephrase or yeah you state
that question and I'll state it even
broader do you know after the ski
Collision of your dad
like being knocked out
no all right in his deposition he
described three major events since the
ski Collision one was that getting
knocked out you never heard of that
no another was cutting himself by
accident I have heard that and he said
it looked like a crime scene there's
blood all over the place is that what he
said
I think I'm cool I don't think I made
that up okay anyway because I got that
photo and it scared the bejesus out of
me okay you get it after it was all
cleaned up and pretty
because I'm not sure which photo you're
talking about I think I've seen one of
the place was it on his inner thigh
I I don't know exactly he's not show me
where where that happened okay just so
we're on the same page
I'm not sure what photo you're talking
about what photo did you see
um
after Mark saved my Dad's life
um my dad took a picture of the bathtub
which is where he was holding up I think
and it was awful awful okay and it's not
gwyneth's fault that he cut himself uh
and had to go to the hospital true
there's
it is
just just well sustained as to relevance
okay
the third major event your dad described
to me was an accidental overdose of his
own medication do you know anything
about it yes I do
and they had to administer Narcan to
reverses the opioids in a system that's
true and are you blaming Gwyneth Paltrow
for that
how could I
development sustainous irrelevance
the day of the event we've seen a few
pictures
but I think you've seen one you
described where he was in the InstaCare
smiling
in a wheelchair do you recall this
I didn't I recall it or I don't
I I don't know the location
I do recall seeing my dad with a smile
that I've never seen and
on a person's face before and that was
the date of the incident right I don't
know I don't have a recollection of when
I got that or what day it was well you
brought it up when we were quizzing you
about your memories and uh
a picture of my dad in a wheelchair with
a big smile right yeah cheesy not him
smile yes
okay
uh do you recall your dad describing
Gwyneth Paltrow as Godzilla
coming
like this Godzilla was coming after him
no okay I didn't make that up Godzilla
was coming is that what you understood
your dad to describe to you
in terms of uh Gwyneth
no all right when you said Godzilla in
your deposition
which I'm looking right at it yes what
were you referring to
so
um I believe in a video
that I watched of my dad talking about
the
Collision
that
essentially he's skiing down the green
run with the
beginning I don't want the whole story
okay essentially what he said what he
said is I heard a scream from behind me
a blood curling scream and that blood
curling is my word
like Godzilla was coming
and then he was hit directly
between the shoulder blades
driven to the ground and you personally
don't know what happened
I was not there
and your dad after uh he says after the
Collision he doesn't remember things for
a while is that fair
I wasn't in his body I don't know what
he does and doesn't remember okay
uh he got his information
from his ski buddy Craig Ramon is that
fair to say is what happened after the
Collision
immediately after
can I have you ask the question again
I'll try it sorry if I was inarticulate
is it fair to say that your dad got all
of his information about what happened
after the Collision
in the minutes after from Craig Ramon
sustained
when you said uh you saw a video of your
dad that was at a press conference he
held is that true I don't recall it it's
a long time ago did your dad sorry to
interrupt you were you done I am done
did you tell me that your dad was not
used to Googling his name and having
lots of
search engines results come up
overruled
did I tell you that right can you say
that again
please
your dad would send you links after he
filed the lawsuit
about press that was mentioning him do
you agree
he would keep me informed of what was
going on
and he kind of thought it was cool that
he that his name was in in press do you
agree
I don't think he said that it was cool
he told me
he thought it was cool that he was in a
ski collision with an accident with a
celebrity he told me that in his
deposition does that surprise you
that surprises me that he would say that
me too
would you remember
what he said
do you agree you would have a better
memory of how your dad was doing
immediately after the accident at the
time you sent the email nine hours after
the accident
you would like today have a better
memory right most likely
has your dad told you that even now
he comes up with new memories of what
happened about the accident that he
hadn't had before
overruled
could you please ask the question would
it surprise you to hear that your dad
said that he still comes up when last
time I did when I deposed him he's still
coming up with new memories of the
accident
sustained I'll just move on and ask your
dad that so it's a little hard to it's
hyper through him no
foreign
wrote I'm famous as his first that was
his uh I guess the call that's 6 30ish
or something and then an email at eight
or so right those were his first
contacts with you
I can't remember the order I think we
determined the phone call happened first
right and from that you got he's okay
and from the second one he wrote I I'm
famous
Fair those were your first two contacts
with them after the Collision
I can't remember exactly without looking
at the deposition and you guys figured
that out for me you mentioned your dad
was an extrovert and that does that
generally mean he he likes people he's
outgoing he gets energy from being
around other
but also he lacks attention you told me
that is that a true of your dad even
before the ski Collision
sustained
thank you I forgot that
he likes to look even before the ski
accident he liked to always look the
best he could
when interacting with others he took
some pride in that
he took good care of himself and uh
have you seen in your dad's some measure
of Pride as his limitations physical and
mental limitations have increased with
aging
I'm having a hard time understanding
sure
you understand generally this concept of
as people age
their
there can be limitations imposed on them
physically and emotionally
is that fair
as a person ages that's correct all
right and have you observed in your dad
separate from the ski collisions some
measure of
sort of loss of pride in as as those
things have occurred
we're talking about before this key
accident
correct yes no all right did he consider
himself like I'm never gonna I'm never
gonna grow old I'm gonna be as active as
I ever was
I think when he lost his parents so he
knew that death would be inevitable
someday
I don't know if that's answered answered
your question
my staff tells me I'm getting long so
I'm gonna try to move this along I do
have a plane flight to catch too
okay thank you
do you believe your father has a clear
recollection of who hit who in the ski
accident
he has a clear recollection of hearing a
scream and and getting hit from behind
and he was knocked out this is literally
the question from your deposition so I'm
going to read it and see if your answer
is yes
do you believe your father has a clear
recollection of who hit whom whom in the
ski accident and your answer
and my deposition was yes
and would it surprise you if he takes
the stand in like two hours and says no
I don't
if that surprise you when would it
surprise you
contradicts you in like two hours
actually as I reread my deposition I
thought you didn't even answer that
correctly of course he doesn't know who
hit him because he got knocked out so
that was my belief at the time and I was
like I didn't read that question or hear
that question correctly and you did have
an opportunity to make corrections to
your deposition did you not I did and
you did not make that correction
um I actually
took did you make that correction or not
I made the corrections and I did not
submit that in time because I was told
by my dad's attorneys that that will be
a red flag and to just drop it
and I did not submit that
revised so did you make other
corrections to your deposition that your
dad's lawyers told you not to submit I
had made yes or no
did could you make other corrections to
your deposition that your deaf lawyers
told you not to not to give me
yes or no
I need Corrections the answer is yes
it's not a simple yes and no
well
I'm not happy if you make corrections to
your deposition that were never sent to
me so I'm wondering you made corrections
to your deposition
and you gave them to your death lawyers
no I did not I did not give them to my
dad's lawyers
can I rely on your deposition here
um
can you rely on it
at the moment in time I believe that
that my dad knew who hit him as I reread
it later at home I thought
that you answered it wrong today
so what are some other Corrections that
you've made to your deposition that we I
can't I never heard of until this I
can't remember I think one was that they
kept calling Zakia Jackie
some mostly were just minor
clarification
do you understand why I might be a
little irritated and hearing that you
made changes that I never got
the
they never got submitted
your dad was a workaholic is that fair
later in my life he became a workaholic
when my parents
uh relationship
was not as good as it used to be
your dad prior to the ski Collision
forgot to tell you that he loved you
very much do you agree
I'm going to have you restate that these
are your words your Dad forgot to tell
me that he loved me very much
is that true of your dad prior to the
ski Collision
I just say yes or no please
for my town
I I don't recall growing up I'm not
making this quota
growing up he forgot to tell me
sure I can page 78 line
16.
I'm not trying to no if it's there in
the deposition I want the quote he
forgot to tell me he loved me very much
do you agree
this goes to his affection level of
affection after the ski Collision
overruled so just say yes or no and
we'll move on
I'm sorry one more time and I'll do my
best I may not be able to answer yes or
no
your dad
okay quote from you you forgot
exactly what I just said 78 find 17. he
forgot to tell me he loved me very much
did you say those words
yes
that could be helpful
he did hug you
just do you are you are you impeaching
the witness or what are we doing here
what do we why don't we take a recess
it's time for the afternoon recess and
we'll address it
all right take a quick break I think
they want the full sentence and I'm
going to give the full sentence
because totally reasonable I mean this
has gone Way Beyond the scope of direct
yeah
so the scope of direct is not not
limited by time
it's limited by topics and we were 25
minutes certainly less than a half hour
half an hour less than oh my gosh
what time do you need to leave
thank you
your flight is at 5 30.
so when do you need to leave I'll let
you work that out for lawyers right now
all right
Mr OMG May proceed
uh your dad was loving to you right he
gave you hugs every day
sorry yes he did he supported you he
a good cheerleader for you as a father
he's always been there for me
quote I said he forgot to tell me you
love me very much
I salute it but I got a daily hug from
him at least that was to the end of the
statement too yeah yes thank you
um
did you tell me earlier in your
deposition that your dad was well
respected in the community
until he had the point of an affair
go ahead yes or no did you tell me your
your dad had an affair and he was
respected in the community until that
point
and then he was not I did tell you that
your dad on his hearing impairment
before the incident even with his
hearing aids he would leave he would
uh to lip read is that fair to say
I don't know that
my client tells me to land the plane
and so I quit I'm done thank you thank
you Council
okay hopefully you'll make your airplane
thank you all right
does the defense have any reason to call
her back no okay so you're completely
released from any legal obligation here
thank you
you may call your next Witness
to call Gwyneth Paltrow thank you
hi do you swear that the testimony you
are about to give in the case now before
the court will be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth so help
you God thank you
good afternoon
there seems like evening doesn't it I've
been inside all day I have no idea
we both
state your name and spell it for the
record please yes my legal name is
Gwyneth Kate Paltrow falchuk that's
g-w-y-n-e-t-h k-a-t-e
p-a-l-t-r-o-w-f-a-l-c-h-u-k great thank
you may I call you miss Paltrow sure
okay fantastic
as you've seen the last few days we
always have the witnesses give
background information tell about
yourself Etc I have a feeling that
everybody in the courtroom knows who you
are so we're not going to go through all
the background we're just going to kind
of cut to the chase is that fair so fine
all right wonderful let's just talk
about skiing
my understanding is that you are pretty
much an intermediate type skier
I would characterize myself as
intermediate
media you've been skiing since you were
a child
I have okay
um do you do black diamonds Blues greens
I'm not really a skier so you've got to
kind of help me out with this I prefer
to do more Blues than blacks okay and
blue is intermediate right under black
yes okay and the bandana run where this
accident occurred it was a green room
yes all right recollection fantastic so
as an intermediate skier would you say
that you skied enough to at least be
familiar with the rules of skiing I
think so yes all right and what are
those rules
I think you know use
Common Sense he safely be aware of other
skiers around you
okay
what about skiing in control is that
something that you need to do yes
absolutely
um you have to give the right of way to
those who are downhill yes okay
you also have certain responsibilities
if you're in a collision is that fair
yes which I learned more about post the
Collision I bet you've probably been hit
over the head with all of that
information since the time right
so let's talk about those things
did you know the rules at the time of
the Collision that if you're in a
collision with someone you need to give
your name and information contact
information
so because I was hit by Mr Sanderson and
he was at fault I assumed that Eric who
was our ski instructor who was there at
the time who was overseeing the event he
said I'm going to leave all of your
information and he said you should go
ski down because my kids were waiting
for me but
skiing if you are in a collision that
you need to share that information
claim
overruled I've
overruled go ahead
can you repeat the question absolutely
at the time of the Collision were you
aware of the rule that if you're in a
collision you need to share your name
your contact information with the person
that you're involved in a collision with
I don't think I was aware of the rule
okay
were you aware that there is kind of a
rule of common decency to do that
I
would not have left the scene without
leaving my information and my
information was left
did you provide that information
no Eric Christensen who was the ski
instructor with us said he would leave
all the information you don't know if he
did or did not though do you
subsequently I know that he did I'm not
asking that I'm asking when you were
there at the Collision you didn't ensure
that it was given you weren't there when
it was given
I was not there when it was given
all right and it's also I think you even
admitted in your deposition that it's
the rule of common decency to make sure
that everybody's okay exchange
information and to follow those skiing
rules is that fair yeah okay
all right so let's talk about that day
after I get a drink okay
I'll have one as well
I do thank you
so I just want to kind of set the stage
um you're skiing that day my
understanding it was a nice conditions
beautiful day yes yes sorry
um and Deer Valley we know that Deer
Valley is always immaculately groomed
good conditions on slopes good
conditions all right you were skiing
that day with your daughter Apple
correct yes Moses my son and
um Brad felchuk who was your boyfriend
at the time now current husband correct
all right and his two children that's
right right and his kids were the same
approximate age as yours on the day of
the ski Collision they all remain the
same age
[Music]
girls are the same age boys are the same
age all right and back then
12 and 9.
11 and 9 11 and 9. all right fantastic
and the day of the Collision I think you
um had been to Deer Valley twice
prior to that I believe so okay and this
was the first day of your ski trip
I think that's correct okay and I don't
know how many days you were there but I
know at least from what you've told us
that after that first day you also skied
the next day yes okay so when Mr
Sanderson was at home you were skiing I
don't know okay fair enough
so the children all four of them had
lessons during that trip that's right
okay
would you agree that those lessons were
fairly expensive they were okay do you
remember about how much they were
um I would have to check whatever the
Deer Valley raid is is what we we paid
okay if let me know if this is about
right at least from what I saw in your
deposition the total bill was around 8
980 does that sound about right for four
yeah I think that misstates the evidence
I think that was for both families for
for four
would honestly have to check okay all
right do you that's that's fine but it's
very expensive very expensive very right
and then tips on top of that yes okay
and I'm assuming
in your under oath here that you're a
good Tipper
yes okay fantastic I wouldn't expect
anything less
um all right so let's talk about your
daughter Apple she was 11. she was okay
and her instructor was Carrie Oaks
that's correct all right and um Apple at
the time was a good beginner
yes okay
okay and your son Moses he was nine at
the time yes and he was more so of a
real beginner yes all right and his
instructor was Eric Christensen correct
okay and I think both Carrie Oaks and
Eric are coming next week
I believe so all right fantastic so
three days ago
um can you believe it's been only three
days no me neither so three days ago uh
Mr Owens
um in his opening talked about
risky Behavior risky skiing and he made
mention that you know of course Miss
Paltrow was not skiing
um recklessly not taking any kind of
risky Behavior because her children were
there that day do you recall him saying
that
I think it does mistake my testimony but
well it wasn't testimony that you stated
can you answer the question
if I remember what he said no just maybe
do you agree with that that on that day
of the Collision you were not engaging
in in any kind of risky Behavior
especially because your kids were there
I was not engaging in any risky Behavior
okay but also and I think your Council
made mention of this in opening that
especially because your children were
there
I don't recall him saying that all right
well did your children being there
um make it so that you especially would
not engage in Risky Behavior
I I didn't engage in Risky Behavior I
wouldn't with my children there or
without my children there okay and kind
of in life I mean I'm a mom right I've
got a couple kids
um actually about your age and one of
them not your age your daughter's age
sorry I'm not that old
um
when my kids are around I kind of behave
myself a little bit better especially
when they were younger than on average
would you agree with that
I I've always been very open and honest
with my kids and um some I I think you
know
they know me very well right and would
you agree that you have engaged in Risky
Behavior with your children present
your honor may we approach sure
we're all back thank you
um so the the objection is sustained and
the jury should disregard the question
yeah
all right let's go back to the day of
the accident okay so you're on bandana
correct it's a green run
um it's true you were relatively
familiar with that run correct yes my
children especially like that run okay
but not at the bottom correct all right
um and it sounds like from what I have
heard and reviewed um you had done about
four to five runs that day and you and
kind of the group are going to go get
some lunch with everyone correct all
right
so
let's talk about as you're skiing down
Apple we've talked about she was 11
Moses was nine
did your children when they were skiing
or doing anything that kids do like to
ask you to watch them
when they were very little I remember
you know watch me jump in the pool and
things like that when they were more
like
four or five years old that sort of age
so when Moses was nine he didn't say
Mommy Mommy watch me or Mom I don't know
what he called you
mama mama watch me watch me do things
not that I recall on that day okay
do you remember testifying that on that
day that's exactly what did happen
I don't remember all right and I'll show
you your deposition in just a second so
in fact during you remember the
deposition right yes it was actually
during 2020 it was during covid yes so
it was via Zoom we've never actually met
in person it was kind of on the video
um and you were asked to question a
number of times you know were you
was were your children
um
asking you to watch them and you said no
I think you I don't remember them saying
watch me on that day okay well do you
remember that in that deposition then we
played you parts of karaoke's deposition
so your honor this is improper
impeachment I mean what's the question
that's being contested we're just kind
of going through the the history here
not through the deposition let's allow
I'll allow a few questions I think
Council was referring to what was going
on during depositions but yes please get
quickly to the question absolutely do
you remember during your deposition
being played just a portion of um
Apple's instructor Carrie Oaks her
deposition wherein she said that yes
Moses was saying mommy mommy watch me
that she was saying I I don't remember
that she that while they were skiing
they were saying that yeah I don't
remember that no all right okay okay and
so you don't remember them changing your
testimony in your deposition admitting
that that is what happened
I I I'm I'm sure of Carrie Oaks said I'm
saying I don't remember him saying watch
me watch me okay
you may
gonna hand you a copy of your deposition
I'm gonna need my reading glasses
unfortunately
I don't think there's an uh a
contradiction here your honor she said
uh she doesn't recall that Carrie Oaks
said something
so I don't I don't know why we can't
just move forward
overruled go ahead thank you
turn
yes okay
and I'm going to read the question that
was given by Mr Sykes
everybody's gonna know it's Mr Sykes who
asked the question when I read it then
I'm going to have you answer
now miss Paltrow and this is I'm sorry I
apologize I'm starting on line four okay
okay now miss Paltrow isn't it true
isn't it true I'm just a country lawyer
here
okay isn't it true that your kids wanted
to watch you ski or pardon me that the
the kids wanted you to watch them ski
isn't that true
and your your Council he objected how
did you answer that question let's read
the objection your honor if we're going
to do this the objection was vague as to
time
the role in the objective I mean if
we're going to read it then we should
read the objection okay read it yes the
the objection said vague as to time
can still watch my children ski and be
skied directly into my back by someone
and then you continued
which is what happened exactly so you
were watching your children when you
allege that you were skied directly into
your back by someone my daughter was
down the hill my son was to my left so I
was skiing my eyes were not fixated only
on my son when Mr Sanderson skied
directly into my back okay
so when
's Oaks who's going to testify next week
said that your son Moses was saying
mommy mommy watched me
that's who you were watching right
that's Vegas to Time
right right be right yes overruled go
ahead thank you
sorry what was the question when when
Moses is saying mommy mommy watched me
that's who you were looking at when you
were direct once when you were skied
directly into your back
I
do not recall Moses saying mommy mommy
watched me on the ski slope okay well
Apple was down further right yes she
didn't see it no okay and Moses he was
the one at least according to Carrie
Oaks was calling your attention
okay okay
um nine-year-old did he want more
attention to have somebody watch them
rather than 11
not necessarily okay Moses was skiing
above you though right he hadn't gotten
down as far as you he was on my left
and up
I was on the right he was oops sorry
he was on the left side of the slope
um yes I believe kind of a little bit
uphill okay and that's where your
attention was when you were hit
allegedly in the back I don't know where
my attention was the moment I was stuck
in the back I'm sorry okay well that's
what you said which is what happened he
struck me in the back yes that's exactly
what happened okay I know but you said I
can still watch my children ski yes
meaning directly into my back by someone
which is what happened yes exactly
what's the pending question it sounds
like they're saying the exact same thing
what's the question the question is
you were watching your children ski when
you were struck in the back let's ask
and answered
overruled
I was skiing and looking downhill as you
do and I was skied directly into by Mr
Sanderson okay
to my recollection okay
all right and karaoke is the one who
says that he was the one calling your
attention you'll have to speak to miss
Oaks we will all right
so
I want to go through
the accident a bit because
we did this over video we didn't really
get to act it out a whole heck of a lot
but I want to just kind of talk with you
first
um and and see if this is your
recollection of of how it happened
your honor I think this is improper she
should just ask her what happened then
if she testified contrary to that
earlier then she crossed examines her
with the deposition and what's the
objection
improper use of deposition testimony
it's a party under rule 32 it can be
used for any purpose
seed thank you
you were going along relatively slowly
is that fair
yes okay I'm just going to kind of ask
you a couple questions so let me know if
anything I say is is not accurate okay
so you're going down relatively slowly
when all of a sudden you heard a strange
rustling noise behind you yes okay
and you felt like a rush of air in a
strange way yes okay
that's correct and all of a sudden there
was a body from the whole front of a
body pressing into my back that's right
okay
like
we'll talk about this in a minute and
there was a man behind me pressing into
me how did you know it was a man
because he was making some strange
noises that sounded male and he was
large so I assumed it was a male okay he
was large
I felt all my back okay depressing okay
um all right there was a man pressing
behind me pressing into me I was
extremely upset
well I was confused at first and I
didn't know exactly what was happening
it's a very strange thing to happen on a
ski slope
um I agree
and I froze and it I would say I was got
very upset a couple seconds later okay
let me just continue on here I just
wanted to make sure that I got this all
right I didn't know if it was an
intentional assault of a sexual nature
right okay
was he grinding and thrusting or
something or just the noises what's what
what made you think it was a a sexual
assault so that was a quick thought that
went through my head when I was trying
to reconcile what was happening I was
skiing and two skis came between my skis
forcing my legs apart and then there was
a body pressing against me and there was
a very strange grunting noise so my
brain was trying to make sense of what
was happening I thought
am I is a practical joke is someone like
doing something perverted this is really
really strange my mind was going very
very quickly and I was trying to
ascertain what was happening okay
um I think you said I didn't know if it
was an accident but he was groaning and
grunting in a very disturbing way yes
there was a sort of grown coming out of
his mouth okay then you said I froze yes
we kept skiing
right we went to the right yes we came
crashing down together that's right okay
you said this man was behind me on the
mountain my knee and our skis will were
still sort of Tangled Up
is that yes yes sorry our bodies were
almost spooning and I moved away quickly
yes and I need and my knees splayed open
and I was completely in shock yes okay
all right I'm gonna stop there okay and
if the court and Miss Paltrow if you
don't mind since again when we did this
over Zoom would you mind stepping down
and US kind of acting this out a little
bit so I could get a good feel let's see
can we approach her on her sure
foreign doesn't mind if I acted out
correct let's
rejection was sustained as requested but
um you know you're welcome to move
around the courtroom wonderful thank you
do you have a
testing
okay Miss Paltrow so your your Council
doesn't want you to come down so I'm not
going to ask you to come down that's
inappropriate the judge sustained the
objection so she shouldn't comment on on
what I want it's what the judge wants
the objection was sustained
I am going to try and be both you and
let's have Bob Bob
I don't want to we're not going to
reenact what happened I think you can
ask questions and yes if you want to
stand and move around in order to help
you with those questions you can do that
but that's as far as we're going to go
that's that's not a problem at all all
right so since you're not down here
um may I ask how tall you are I'm just
under 5 10. okay I am so jealous I think
I'm shrinking though you and me both I
have to wear four inch heels just to
make it to five five so they're very
nice oh thank you so all right so as of
right now I'm Gwyneth Paltrow okay okay
I'm skiing down can you tell me with my
legs
I don't know again I'm not much of a
skier are you snowplowing are you
parallel kind of Orient my legs first of
all
sorry
I can do this I can do this not snow
plowing just okay skis
all right it's hard for me to see what
you're where you're standing may she
come down just to to see you can you can
is that okay you can see better you can
walk further forward oh sure great
no problem all right so
Jerry you can go ahead and stand or move
wherever you feel you need to to see
what's going on here
all right so
are my feet oriented correctly
yes go ahead and tell me how to move
them I think you know skiing down going
to the right okay so probably a little
bit further apart okay about like that
and then two skis slide slowly between
my skis all right so
my feet are about what a foot apart
would you say 18 inches probably okay
and you believe that two skis
slid right between that is correct okay
and so all of a sudden you see these two
skis coming in between your legs I would
have freaked out too and I did okay so
so the skis are coming how how far did
the skis
get in between your legs before
you guys fell
his body pressed up into my back okay so
I froze I don't know exactly how far the
skis would have come through okay
because then I noticed his body pressing
against my back okay and then it was
probably a few good seconds and then we
felt to the right somebody must have
caught an edge okay so when you guys are
when you froze and you're skiing
together I think you said at one point
you it was like you were spooning well
when we fell down we fell I fell on his
body he fell on the ground and so it was
kind of like a spoon on the ground okay
so here
it's fine I think
um well now that Mr Sanderson is here
and I don't need you to do anything
Terry but
um just for comparison's sake I'm in my
heels we're about the same height
about five five with heels
roughly oh tell me I'm taller please
okay so so you we've got Mr Sanderson
that's about five five that comes in
back of you and you've said that you
felt something huge what was your word
just a big a big body a big body all
right and was it just the front of his
body that touched the back of your body
I couldn't see in the back of my head
sure but I felt a body press against my
back there was no grabbing like nobody
that he didn't like grab your waist or
grab you no not at all no like that
nothing okay
all right
so
skis slide between you kind of freeze
you you end up maybe your skis kind of
cross you end up going down would you
agree that Mr Sanderson
fell to the ground and then you fell on
top
I don't know if it was simultaneous I
don't remember but you didn't fault and
hit the ground correct I don't remember
exactly where I hit okay but I fell over
all right and with Mr Sanderson right
and Mr Sanderson fell and hit the ground
yes
[Music]
all right so
going back here
um
you guys are on the ground
now you you realize right you're and
you're not saying to the jury that this
was in any way shape or form a sexual
assault I am not saying that I'm just
saying what went through my mind for a
split second when it was happening all
right great so you're down on the ground
and then you started yelling at him
I I don't remember if I started yelling
at him while I was on the ground I
remember pushing away because I was very
upset and it was still very strange to
me what had happened
um and I pushed down the hill and I
turned around and I said and I yelled at
him okay did you scream before you went
down
so if others heard a scream you wouldn't
that wasn't you no I froze when he slid
between my skis I absolutely froze and I
don't remember yelling or Screaming
until I was very angry at what had
happened okay and so you guys are on the
ground
um and then you said to him I think you
don't know if you were up or if you were
still on the ground but he was still on
the ground right yes when you said what
are you doing yes okay like why did you
do that yes and he said I think you
skied into me yes and that's when you
were Furious and said you skied directly
into my effing back
at the top of your lungs yes I did okay
I apologize for my bad language I in
fact you were
you were worried that Moses was hearing
you yes
and after you were screaming to him
isn't that when Mr Sanderson said I'm
sorry I'm sorry he said I said you skied
directly into my effing back and he said
oh sorry sorry I'm sorry right and that
was you screaming at him while he's on
the ground still
right I was yelling at him pretty loud
I was pretty upset right you're small
But Mighty
actually you're not that small
um so
when he said I'm sorry I'm sorry would
you agree that he kind of mumbled it yes
okay all right
um
and then you remember Eric came over
Eric Christensen yes who was Moses's
instructor correct okay and
um that was when you were concerned that
oh gosh Moses is close by he's hearing
me yell obscenities at this man which is
not my custom right and I think you said
that and at some point the man stood up
and we were all sort of talking yes what
conversation did you have with Mr
Sanderson standing up I wasn't having a
conversation with him Eric was helping
him up and asking if he was okay okay
Eric eventually yanked him up right he
pulled him up he helped him up okay he
didn't get up on his own accord he
helped him and were you still standing
right there when he helped him I believe
I was yeah you sure you hadn't skied
down a little bit because I might have
skied down a little bit my son was down
a little bit and my now husband came
over at some point okay
um
so I and I remember moving away from Mr
Sanderson after he collided into me and
we hit the ground okay and do you
remember
um we heard from Craig Ramon he was the
first individual who testified do you
remember him coming to the scene
I do not you don't remember him at all
remember him being there or asking you
are you okay I do not okay you don't
remember him asking Terry if he was okay
I don't recall
okay all right
and then
I think what you've said is Eric told
you I'm gonna handle this and that's
what I think you said people do they
handle things for you
I don't believe I said that you've never
said that I believe what I said was in
the acting world that's a world of
Representatives you have an agent who
represents you and so if they say you
know I'm gonna provide information you
allow somebody to represent you so when
Eric as an accredited Deer Valley Ski
instructor said to me I'll fill out the
paperwork he knew also that my daughter
was at the bottom waiting for me to come
for lunch or at the lunch place
and so Mr Christensen handled it for you
Mr Christensen stayed and filled out the
report made sure Mr Sanderson was okay
and said to me you can go ahead how do
you know that if you weren't there
because he told me
that's what he told you yes but you
weren't there to see it
told you you can leave he wasn't there
objective form I don't know sustained go
ahead with your questions
you weren't there when the paperwork or
the exchange of information was given
fair fair all right
and um
would you agree that
Mr Christensen did not see the incident
didn't see the Collision correct he just
saw us right afterwards right but in
fact nobody from Deer Valley has seen
saw the Collision correct your kids
didn't see the Collision that's right
okay the only person that and you may
not be aware of this the only person who
says that they saw the Collision was Mr
Ramon
yes
okay do you the way you answer that
makes me think that you don't believe
that he saw it
I did not believe his testimony
do you believe that he saw the Collision
no I don't believe that he saw what he
thinks he saw
Miss Paltrow why would he lie
this is a man it's a motive your honor
perhaps that's not the right
objection under the rules so let me be
quiet and withdraw my objection
can you answer it
he said he was at 40 feet away and
colorblind
I don't know how he can be positive
about what he saw especially with how
much he changed his story
well what does colorblind have to do
with anything my husband's colorblind we
tease him all the time but he can't tell
red or green but what does that have to
do with not seeing who hit who well if
you have two people in ski gear with
helmets on and you're 40 plus feet away
I'm not sure how you can discern who is
who
okay well and I can tell you that he
didn't because Mr Sanderson
categorically hit me on that ski slope
and that is the truth
and I'm sure that that's what you
believe I'm not saying because it's the
truth I'm not saying that
um let's get a question so you and Mr
Sanderson if you're almost 5 10 Terry's
five five pushing it your honor that's
that's not an Evidence Council you'll
have an opportunity to redirect or to
direct examine so if you two stood next
to each other do you think that somebody
would confuse
I don't know I'm telling you what
happened
okay
all right
so
you're screaming at Terry worried that
Moses hears you you admit that you were
shaken up yes okay
um
you don't recall Mr Ramon
be eating there I do not or asking you
if you were okay I do not did anybody
ask you if you were okay I remember Eric
Christensen asking me if I was okay and
Brad my now husband asking me if I was
okay okay and when you talk to Brad he
was down further right yeah with Moses
so none of that took place where my
client was he came over to me after the
fall
and
injuries Mr Sanderson did or did not
sustain in the accident I do not okay
are you aware now that you sat here the
last three days that he did sustain four
broken ribs yes okay aware that he
sustained a concussion yes okay
um are you aware that he had to be taken
down on a toboggan so
so does she know as a result of
testimony or does she know personally
would you clarify your question yeah
sure
um
how how did you learn that Hebrew bro
four ribs
this okay and and to make it clear I
don't want to find out anything that
your lawyers told you that's
attorney-client privilege we can't so
anytime I'm asking you I don't want you
to tell me what your lawyers have have
told you okay um
through the court proceedings is that
fair that's fair all right you learned
that Mr Sanderson broke four ribs yes
okay and then he sustained a concussion
correct okay that he went was taken down
on toboggan yes did you learn of that
that day no did you inquire
what is your name again sorry
Kristen yes sorry I was gonna say
Kristen sorry I think you have to keep
in mind when you're the victim of a
crash right your psychology is not
necessarily thinking about the person
who perpetrated it
so the answer to my question is no you
did not inquire okay did you ever
um ask hey how was that guy that ran
into the back of me is he okay do you
ever ask anybody from Deer Valley about
that I did not because at the time I did
not know that he had sustained injuries
like that I thought it was very minor on
the day and you didn't stick around long
enough to find that out I stuck around
long enough for him to say he was okay
to stand up that he told Mr Christensen
he was okay and when he's when he was
helped up by Mr Christensen again you
weren't right there you were down a ways
just a few feet down yes could you tell
if Mr Sanderson was still dazed or
unsteady on his feet I I could not I
don't know okay
and again you didn't leave your name
address contact information you didn't
fill out any paperwork in connection
with this accident
Eric did on my behalf right but I'm
asking about you personally well it has
been asked an answer
sustained okay
after
the incident you skied down went to
lunch and then my understanding is you
got a massage
so after the accident I met all the rest
of the kids at lunch we all gathered we
had lunch
and I still felt very shaky and my knee
was bothering me my back was bothering
me so I decided to go in early and get a
massage okay
um you never did seek any kind of
medical treatment for your knee or your
back no okay
um now at the scene before you skied
down and and had lunch
um
there was no indication that Mr
Sanderson knew who you were is that fair
I don't know okay I think well you
testified there was no indication of
that you were wearing goggles a helmet
yes okay kind of looked like everybody
else on the slope
that's always my intention okay
probably had a better ski outfit though
I bet I still have the same one I just
have one okay so nobody on the hill
would be able to recognize you is that
fair
maybe your face I have friends I have
been recognized on ski slopes before
okay do you recall testifying in your
deposition that no one in the hit on the
hill would be able to recognize me
that would be the idea okay but
sometimes Paparazzi has a way of
figuring it out is my point okay
Mr Sanderson skied into you that is
correct all right
um
Craig Ramon you said he's not telling
the truth or you don't believe him
I don't I I'm telling you that what he
said is not what happened Okay so in
other words if somebody says something
that's not what happened they're lying
he is not telling the truth all right I
don't know if he knows he's lying but
I'm telling you what he said is
unfortunately not the truth all right
well
and Mr Ramon you've sat here when some
of the experts have testified we had
um Dr Gibby and we heard Dr
Fame I always want to say bomb or bone
Fame you've heard their testimony that
the only way that Mr sanderson's ribs
could have been broken where they were
is that if he was hit from behind you
disagree with that I think it misstates
their testimony
I guess I'm not sure what the objection
is but it's overruled the jury will have
to remember what the testimony was
that made you get to answer you disagree
with their testimony absolutely I
disagree okay
um
what medical training do you have to
disagree with that I'm just telling you
the truth of what actually happened okay
okay that's all I can do all right
and you don't have any other Witnesses
saw it
Port you your position
correct
well I have a lot of witnesses who saw
the split seconds afterwards and the
positions of the bodies on the mountain
which would indicate very clearly who
hit who
okay do you have any Witnesses who saw
it who saw the Collision no all right
and you're not trained in accident
reconstruction
me yeah no neither am I
so
Miss Paltrow isn't it true that
this was an accident that you caused no
ma'am okay
um would you agree that you are accident
prone
so your honor can we have a bench
meeting on this why don't we take our
recess now
Mr Owens
yes
your owner why are we dealing with
things that have been addressed
on pre-trial motions and I have to
object
number 14
previous unrelated injuries the Court's
ruling on that was that it appears the
plaintiff does not intend to inquire
into the areas covered by that motion
I think it was represented to the court
and the motion was therefore granted
the ruling would be Revisited if the
defendant opens the door to these areas
of evidence at trial what's the
relevance let's say she's clumsy there's
been no testimony that clumsiness in any
way contributed to the accident your
honor we also mentioned during that
court hearing that questions were asked
repeatedly in Ms Paltrow's deposition if
she was accident prone to which she said
no I am not which she has admitted a
number of times that she is so this is
all impeachment evidence and that's when
the court said okay that's impeachment
please provide that information to
council which I did he has all of the
Articles
Etc and the video where Miss Paltrow
went on Jimmy Kimmel saying yes I am
accident-prone I am always running into
things
which is which is I'm a which is
very relevant to this case she's how
because we believe that that's exactly
what she did is she ran into things like
she always does she was asked if she
ever said that she said no and we have
impeachment evidence that she has which
but you know your Accident
Reconstructionist did not testify that
that she was that her clumsiness somehow
had played a part in the cause of the
accident it's not just clumsiness it's
that she's running into things that
she's accident-prone absolutely that's
that's the heart of this
and that the point is she was asked a
number of times in her deposition were
you in that part that part I think I see
is collateral impeachment so I don't see
that as I mean I don't see that as your
Avenue to get the evidence in the
closest I guess is your theory of the
case but you've got no expert and no one
that testified that clumsiness somehow
played a part in the accident so it
would just be argument
based on based on kind of Fringe uh
impeachment it's not clumsiness it's
being accident prone and always running
into
into which is what we contend she did in
this case all right let me hear from Mr
Owens
we shouldn't pretend that we have not
had this fight before I'm in deja vu
from two months ago when the judge
already when you already ruled on this
uh
the judge your honor said the ruling
will be Revisited if defendant opens the
door to these areas of evidence at trial
that's part of
page 13. I didn't even have the Motions
around because we've already had it
granted so why would we need to go dig
and find out what our motion said so
your honor Noah Ramon no one Ramone
didn't testify that she looked clumsy
for instance Miss Paltrow never says uh
didn't did not say I've never been
clumsy anyway you've ruled and I'm we're
in deja vu here I've ruled I mean under
under rule 404 evidence of a person's
character or character trait is not
admissible to prove that on a particular
occasion the person acted in Conformity
with the character or trait and under
the Court's motion lemony decision under
it indicates on page 13 motion 14
pertains to her public appearances and
previous unrelated injuries that's the
previous instances of that I believe
that Mr van Norman's referring to and
the Court's order says it appears to
planet does not intend to inquire into
the areas covered by these motions and
the Motions are therefore granted the
ruling will be Revisited if the
defendant opens the door
if that occurs and the plaintiff wishes
to present any of the categories of
evidence he must first address this with
the court out of the presence of the
jury and I guess there wasn't any
request I mean is that what your motion
that is pending is relates to that you
want a clarification no that's regarding
the ski X
prior inconsistent statements your honor
I'm entitled to ask her if she's
testified that she's light under oath a
number of times and I want to be able to
show the jury
this moment well
just a moment just a moment well Counsel
on talking okay have a seat
okay the statement that you just made do
you want to rephrase that yes absolutely
she has made prior inconsistent
statements
during her deposition Miss Paltrow was
asked a number of times three four five
times that may be on this issue that may
be but to me without some witness tying
it into the the essential uh
elements of this case are the essential
issues in this case
I see it as collateral impeachment even
the fact
s and as in she is also walking into
walls
Etc
the ruling was my understanding was that
the plaintiff was not going to inquire
into the areas covered by the Motions
which included that the previous
unrelated injuries or un other instances
of conduct so I'm going to stand by my
ruling I haven't I haven't Revisited it
I think it's a good ruling
there was and I am sorry I'm not like
all I'm saying there were inconsistent
statements I am not trying to slander
Miss Paltrow or nor say that she's lying
By Any Which Way form or form
okay thank you let's take a short break
and come back maybe five after
jury is on its way
okay
yes please
I think the jury's coming
okay you can bring them in
Mr Van Norman you may proceed yes thank
you
so miss Paltrow I want to shift yours a
little bit and talk about kind of
this was where my whole is
Jackson was sustained
um I'm sure it was on the record
whenever it was there I don't I don't
recall
now would be a good time for a bench
but
the objection was sustained
counterclaim so I want to talk with you
about the counter claim
um
is it true that you feel it's unfair
that Mr Sanderson has brought this case
against you I do okay and he has
deterred you from enjoying the rest of
what was a very expensive vacation
well I lost
half a day of skiing
yes okay and
um I think that's
that's what your Council has argued as
well that you lost you had a full day
pass but you can only ski a half a day
yes I went back down after lunch okay
doubt didn't have any kind of medical
attention
no it didn't feel acute in any way it
felt just like I had overstretched my
knee and I had sustained a blow but it
didn't feel like it needed medical
attention okay
okay and you're bringing this claim for
one dollar I am okay in fact your
Council Steve
dollar bill
I'm not even respond to that you you no
I don't get it sure yeah I don't need it
you saw Mr Owens waived that one dollar
around right I did okay
one dollar in symbolic damages is that
accurate
it's an actual dollar that I'm asking
for okay but you also have testified
when I asked you questions in your
deposition that that one dollar is
symbolic
it's symbolic because the damages would
actually be more okay
learned about that through Taylor Swift
because she asked for one dollar in
symbolic damages right and I think I
said at that point I had not been
familiar with it but I since am now you
are but at the time a couple years ago
in 2020 you didn't know anything about
Taylor Swift's one dollar symbolic
damage lawsuit just
Council yeah because I asked her about
it at the time and she denied it
correct can you answer the question
I was not aware at the time
okay are you good friends with Taylor
Swift no
overruled you're not good friends with
Taylor Swift I would not say we're good
friends we are friendly I take my kids
I've taken my kids to one of her
concerts before but we don't talk very
often you've never given Miss Swift
personal
um intimate gifts for Christmas
your honor
uh relevance
bench trial well she's just said that
she wasn't friends with her so
I
don't inquiring on that ask her about
Oprah I mean
Mr Owens uh sustained please move on
you're telling the jury
that you are here asking for one dollar
I am
that's not totally accurate though is it
what do you mean well the jury isn't
going to be deciding this but you're
also asking the judge to award you
attorneys fees for over hundreds of
thousands of dollars isn't that true
uh
the judges made a ruling on this issue
that it will be a separate
stained Ester relevance
the relevance is your honor that they
have you want to argue the relevance we
should do it up here absolutely
oh I'm sorry yes
objections overruled
stated because I know it's been a little
while so it's not true Miss Paltrow that
you're just asking for a dollar you are
also asking this is not for the jury to
decide but this is for the court to
decide later you're asking for your
attorney's fees in this case which could
be quite substantial is that not true
so I'm asking for a dollar for me and
then reimbursement of attorney's fees
which is a separate thing and that could
be a substantial amount correct
potentially okay and when your Council
got up waving that one dollar don't you
think that's a little bit of a
mischaracterization
I have one more question on this issue
and this is now three overruled go ahead
don't you think that that's one dollar
that's a mischaracterization isn't it I
took it as I would receive that one
dollar which is all I am asking for
Miss Paltrow isn't it true that you've
misrepresented a number of things to
absolutely not no other questions
Mr Owens
you've been here every minute of this
jury trial through true and uh you're
intending to be here every minute uh
next week I am uh have you enjoyed
yourself
I've learned a lot
who hit who
Mr Sanderson hit me
the comment was that Mr Sanderson
doesn't take criticism well do you take
criticism well
my profession after all these years
of being in the public eye I think I
take it relatively well
you're sending me notes
I didn't cause these damages
that's absolutely correct
if you feel some empathy for Mr
Sanderson and is
declining brain you know I really do I
feel very sorry for him it seems like
he's had a very difficult life
but I did not cause the accident so I
cannot be at fault for anything that
subsequently happened to him so his
daughter got up and said he was
cursing out her her daughter did you
hear that I did hear that did you cause
that I did not cause that did you give
him brain injuries that were evident on
his MRI in 19
2006. I did not
all right let's start on a happier note
let's bring up that picture of you and
Moses
while that's coming up did you
personally take a selfie with you and
your son
I take selfies with my kids all the time
yes all right and we're going to pull it
up in just a minute you know what
picture I'm talking about did you
personally take that photo I did on the
day at issue I did before the accident
okay and uh
it's hard to tell who the nine-year-old
is there thank you are you on the right
or left I'm on the right and Moses is on
the left yes and are you going up the
ski lift it looks like it this is
defense 86 if we haven't moved for its
admission I would like to do so
then it's 86 is received and
um
I notice do you have a helmet on there I
do and goggles yes
did you always that day while on the
slopes yes Mr Ramon testified for
instance you were not wearing a helmet
or goggles or any face covering
whatsoever a true or it's not true I
think you can see the evidence that I
was wearing helmet and goggles so answer
my questions sorry
is it true or not true that at the time
of the collision and in the aftermath
you were or were not wearing a helmet I
was and goggles correct
uh
uh do did you ski at all that day
without a helmet no is that for an
amenity anonymity thanks for saying that
and also for safety or both or what it's
for safety primarily but yes I like to
when I'm skiing try to keep a low
profile
you were asked about uh well let me let
me back up even further okay uh
you told me you you helped you learned
to ski at Alta
I did actually tell me a little about
that my father was
um loved skiing
skiing later in life
and so he was determined for my brother
and I to learn how to ski When We Were
Young
and he used to do these really sweet
one-on-one ski trips with us where he
would take us to various destinations
and Alto was one of them
and then he died young true
unfortunately did you stop in his 50s
that's how I I'm in my 50s but uh
1950s did you stop skiing for a while
I did
um
I was pretty devastated by his
death and just being in the ski resort
and on a chair left it was
um
it was difficult for me so I avoided it
for a few years until I had my own kids
and then I heard his voice in my head
thinking I should teach him how to ski
and uh Brad falchuk you were dating him
at the time yes now married to him yes
were you skiing with the Coldplay guy a
cold according to
Ramon no he no who's the goal Coldplay
guy
Coldplay guy I believe is he's referring
to my first husband Chris Martin he's
the singer and
he's a guitar player and a piano player
in the band Coldplay
thank you and uh did this uh kind of
blending of the family's trip have some
significance to you
yes this was
um this was a significant trip for us it
was the first time Brad and I were
introducing our kids and doing something
together as to see if we could blend
families
there's an implication that at the time
of this Collision you were distracted
were you distracted no were you paying
attention to where you were skiing I was
was there anyone in front of you there
was not
there's an implication that somehow
you're looking at Moses up the hill to
the left
while you're skiing down hill were you
doing that no it's not
carry Oaks of Deer Valley does say
something in our deposition about
the kids want wanting you to see them or
something were you in fact like did you
all meet at the top of the hill
I think we were so we were six in our
group plus our ski instructors so we
would always meet that day at the top of
the chair and kind of plot out where
everyone was going great
okay the six people let's just make sure
we know who they myself Brad
my stepdaughter Isabella my daughter
Apple my son Moses and my stepson Brody
okay and then uh you had paid for each
of the four kids to have their own
individual instructors they were all
very different levels so Brad paid for
his kids and I paid for mine all right
the one dollar that I'll probably wave
in closing but not this minute
were you were you planning
to ski the whole day I was and
did you send a little text uh after
lunch
yes can you bring this up
has it been admitted so D good question
d110 is the text
any objection
s
exhibit 110 for defendants is received
83a is the better copy I guess
what are you showing so go ahead do you
have
this binder there
I just have my deposition
objection defense exhibit 83b is
received it's a little hard to see okay
James could you blow up the last
sort of yes
I think we need to go back just a little
more to put a date on it
do you recall I asked you hey did you
text anyone that day do you remember
this yes and this is your own personal
cell phone copy yes it is
okay and there's the date sorry it's a
bad copy February 24th sorry February 26
2016. is that
is that in fact a true and correct copy
of your phone screen
yes and who are you texting with do you
recall Eric Christensen the ski
instructor all right so
we went down bandana so you'd already
been down that very uh
oh my board
in case this is better coffee
um
all right okay cool which one's you on
the right or left you know the green I'm
Eric is the green and I'm the white okay
cool we we should take north side up
question mark That's you okay let's go
back out and in the afternoon
let's go with the
okay let's keep going down
oh let's go Ruby left so you're
coordinating a little bit yes on the
mountain in real time correct yes and
then uh
sorry James I'm testing you out here
Moses wants to know if you are still
skiing and where
all right so it's 229 and this is no
one's thinking lawsuit yet right no and
that's you on the left with the G and it
says can you read it it says I came in
that guy sort of hurt me I'm gonna get a
massage at three Gigi is here if he
wants to come
is helping with the kids yeah GG was our
babysitter
all right did you go in earlier because
you had been hit
I did yes
did you personally pay for a ski pass at
Deer Valley I did
and was it a full day pass it was and
was it uh is this monetary difference
between the full day pass and the half
day pass more than one dollar it is
Miss Van Norman kept saying when you
were allegedly hit were you hit I was
hit
the definition of an assault is an
unauthorized touching did Mr Sanderson
touch you in an unauthorized manner
you may
and you should disregard the question
did he touch you without your permission
he did the sexual part by the way that's
just for a split second you're thinking
what's going on here yes I was trying to
put together what could possibly be
happening behind me
scream a scream I think there are a
couple witnesses that said they heard
Some Noise yes uh when we fell is it
impossible you you let out a noise upon
being hit
I think it's impossible that I let out a
noise upon being hit because it was a
very slow
move it wasn't an impact the impact came
when we felt on the ground so it's very
possible that when the impact was made I
screamed but I do not recall making a
sound until we were falling or on the
ground okay
uh
so a collision when I think of two
skiers hitting each other I I think of a
hit
and then sort of separation between the
two yes is that what happened with you
no this was very strange
it was a slow in between my skis with
his skis
and then like one one thousand two one
thousand ish and then a fall the defense
has prepared an animation exhibit that
will be shown next week have you
personally reviewed that I have and does
it uh accurately State what you believe
has uh occurred that day yes now it's
not precise in the sense that it's not
actual video of the event right
um
but it it does a good job of sort of
setting the stage animating what
occurred
part of the animation he's referring to
agree it's
sustained as to vagueness and therefore
relevance sure our our
have you seen the animations I have all
right
not everyone not every witness saw
everything fair to say fair all right
for instance
you didn't see anyone in front of you
but you felt someone behind you yes so
you wouldn't possibly know for instance
where Sanderson was coming from no he
was behind me I'm trying to satisfy the
priority
staying
does the animation uh
fairly represent your story
it does
one thing Craig Ramon uh
said is that Mr Sanderson was out cold
for two or more minutes do you recall
that testimony
to be honest he said so many different
minutes so many times I don't recall
exactly all right assume that he said
minutes okay it's literally unconscious
for minutes did you observe that
that Mr Sanderson was unconscious for
minutes yes or unconscious at all I
don't know based on what I've heard from
the doctors that you can be unconscious
for a split second so it's possible he
was for a Split Second
so
where were you where were you as you go
down the hill
on the right side of bandana was there a
reason you were there
I just tend to try to especially on a
crowded run I was trying to ski you know
a little bit to the side and make
time are you in a were you being an
aggressive skier like I'm gonna go as
fast as I can to get this is a green run
with lots of families absolutely not
it's a green run but it's not a bunny
run right it it actually
I mean it's one of your favorite runs it
was one of my kids favorite ones they
were learning gotcha because it comes
down quite a ways it does it's a nice
long run
and was this toward the top do you
recall it was toward the top but not at
the top if that makes sense
would you have observed
first of all did you personally look and
see Mr Sanderson
on the ground after the event yes
and was he unconscious when you saw him
no
then they're saying Eric Christie
Christensen the Deer Valley person came
over Did You observe that I did
and um
they're saying that he yelled
aggressively toward
Mr Sanderson Did You observe that he did
not yell at Mr Sanderson though
he's going to testify on Monday
um
from your interactions with Mr
Christensen is that consistent with his
personality to be aggressive like that
she knows her character evidence
sustained
how many times before have you
interacted with Mr Christensen
that we had had him teach my son Moses
on at least one other occasion
he was always
incredibly kind very patient my son was
a beginner and frustrated that he
couldn't ski better faster and Mr
Christensen is incredibly patient and
sweet with him
he's a high school art teacher I guess
on the side or yes one of the other he
makes Pottery
uh there was an early comment about a
hit and run did you hit and run
absolutely not
and Deer Valley was dismissed on that uh
was a prior party and was dismissed you
recall that that's correct I think there
was an allegation that
Eric Christian Christensen uh
did some funny business with the
paperwork to protect you his paying
client imagine your honor relevance
sustained
did you uh
expect Eric Christensen to falsify his
paperwork of course not
agent and representative in the legal
world I can tell you it's a little
different than in the acting world right
um this idea that is that when Eric told
me to leave
I felt okay to leave
yes
just comment on that was that a cover-up
no certainly your honor relevance stand
was Eric Christensen your legal
representative on the mountain
overruled on that
go ahead no he was uh
did you stick around for a while after
the Collision I did indeed
going back to the one dollar
Eric Christians you had paid to Eric
Christensen to take uh
to teach her son how to ski that day for
the full day true yes and uh was his
attention diverted as a result of your
Collision yes for a while and that one
dollar of Damages does that
also take into account that fact
I haven't Quantified if you break it out
what a Deer Valley Ski instructor makes
per hour but I think it's more than one
dollar
the comment was the word symbolic was
used but did you in fact lose
one dollar or more as a result of the
Collision
I did
did
you hurt yourself I'm sorry did Mr
Sanderson Hurt You by hitting you he did
and please explain
well when we fell over my right knee
felt like it had been overstretched and
my back hurt
s
but did not seek medical care is that
what I understood I did not
Eric Christians christensen's gonna
testify on Monday he's going to say
words to the effect that he heard and
turned
um
Ramon similarly said that didn't he I
believe he did he wasn't
focused just on Terry right before the
incident he heard and turned and saw
them go a group go down correct that's
what he said
I will let the jury remember them
the question yeah the question the
answer in the code afterward are
stricken you should disregard
Moses and apple are coming and Brad on
Monday morning they are
missing school to do it
Apple will be missing school
unfortunately and Moses will be on
spring break
so he will not be
you've heard next week you will hear
from our experts but do they 100 support
your version of what occurred
yes
said your version of what occurred but I
do mean to say what occurred you know
what occurred right I absolutely do I
was there
when they say did anyone witness this
and Mr Sanderson doesn't really remember
things you remember things don't you I
do
stained
were you knocked out I was not knocked
out no
do you have memory loss of the event
I do not I mean it was a long time ago
but that's fair
one moment please
just one quick thing we're going to
bring up a Deer Valley receipt that
actually shows the amount paid
which number is it
any objection no objection defendants
exhibit 85 is received
foreign
address if we needed to but it turns out
we don't need to so there's been no
objection and James would you bring that
up
there's an address there maybe enlarged
so d85 move for admission if we haven't
and then is this your actual receipt
from Deer Valley
yes and it's it's in that binder in
front of you if you need to look at it
thank you
all right uh it's kind of hard to see
uh the tab between the four of you for a
couple
four kids couple days
nearly nine grand eh
that's what they charge
I think again there's this assertion
that uh because you were paying Eric
Christensen
you expected him to lie for you
dude
overruled the jury will recall the
evidence or the questioning and the
answers before
all right does that mean I I don't
know ah
so did you expect Eric Christiane
Christensen to life for you absolutely
not but he was on your payroll wasn't he
but this is what Deer Valley charges so
anytime you you go and you ask for a
private instructor that's the fee
unfortunately
okay and we'll let Eric talk about this
on Monday okay those are all of my
questions thank you thank you thank you
miss van Orman
I will be quick and I
actually will stay the case
if I can find my glasses all right
to follow up on a couple things you were
just asked about
um
you were shown the text message I think
that's on that board there yes and
Council had asked you that text message
was made before there were any lawsuits
going on right it was okay so are you
aware that Mr Ramon reported to the ski
patrol that you hit Terry in the back
about 10 minutes after the crash
I don't understand the question
are you aware that Mr Ramon about 10
minutes after the accident reported to
ski patrol that you struck Mr Sanderson
in the back I don't think so okay if
that report was made that would 10
minutes after the crash that was long
before a lawsuit was even contemplated
as well isn't it yes
you mentioned about keeping a low
profile you like to keep a low profile
when you're skiing correct
um does screaming at the top of your
lungs profanities at Mr Sanderson when
he's on the ground keeping a low profile
after an incident like that where you
feel hurt and violated unfortunately
adrenaline can take over an emotion as
well
about touching you without your
permission I just want to make clear as
we well we didn't do the little
dance dance yeah it's a little dance
um
but when I tried to reenact it with
myself which is I'm sure I'll get crap
for that later for my children
um it was the front of his body that you
believe touched you right yes not his
arms not his hands correct okay and when
you guys fell to the ground you landed
on him he did not land on you that's
right okay
all right
um you screamed when you fell
the what I remember the first time I
remember yelling was at Mr Sanderson
after the accident but it's possible
that I could have yelled when we were
falling
and then you've described and you kind
of put with your fingers uh how Mr
Sanderson skis
went in between yours
you have any explanation how somebody if
your move because you were moving right
yes he's moving yep
how somebody could I'm just going to
call it thread the needle stick how can
somebody as they're moving down this
hill
have the ability to put their skis in
between yours when they're like 18
inches apart I don't know but that's
what happened okay
um you testified that this was a crowded
run
it was there were people on the Run okay
but you've just said when I asked you
questions earlier nobody was in front of
you
nobody was directly in front of me no
okay were there people in Your Vision in
front of you there were people on the
Run okay it was crowded
it was I don't think I I think it was
moderately crowded on that day okay and
some of the people were your daughter
and Carrie Oaks
Oaks Christiansen to the left and up a
little bit I believe so okay
um and you've mentioned that Mr
Christensen was kind and patient with
your son he was okay very much so all
right
um You did pay him a lot and tip him
well
I paid Deer Valley Resort I don't know
what the resort pays their instructors
so that would be a question for them did
you do you tip Mr Christianson well I
hope so okay me too
um but I would hope also if you're going
to use this and you'd had him as an
instructor before right yes okay you
would expect him to be kind and patient
with your son
well he was kind and patient the first
time which is why we asked to have him
again okay great
um
you said that you stuck around
but while you stuck around you never
asked Mr Sanderson if he was okay
correct because he had hit me and I was
very upset
Mr Christensen asked if he was okay and
he said he was
meaning Mr Sanderson I think you said
that he mumbled it
said I'm okay
uh
you've been asked a number of questions
about
um the dollar
you were asked in your deposition were
you not to your understanding you're
making a claim for the sum of one dollar
as a symbolic law right yes and you said
correct
yes that's right okay
and then I also asked you in your
deposition
are you telling me now you're making a
claim for more sum of a dollar do you
remember what your response was
I don't remember you said no
that's not the case though is it
it's a yes or no
that's an improper question she gave the
answer
overruled
it's a yes or no are you making a claim
more than a dollar in this case now I am
yes thank you no other questions
one more what what's changed between now
and when I took your deposition in 2020
what do you mean well in 2020 you said
no I'm not now you said now you are
what's changed well you're making the so
for me as I said there's a delineation
between the one dollar that I would
receive
and the lawyers fees being reimbursed
which is not to me
oh I am you're not
at the time of the deposition
I was seeking a dollar for myself
and I don't recall at the time of the
deposition if we were also asking for
the reimbursement
I'll represent to you that that was pled
in the counter claim I could show you a
copy if you'd like you could do you
disagree with that
do I disagree with that in the counter
claim with my client and how I got
involved on this case that you had asked
for a Dollar Plus attorney fees I am
asking for first
reimbursements or that they're being
paid
from day one since you filed the counter
claim against Mr Sanderson
yes thank you
we're going to pull up um
P3 which I think has been admitted is a
Deer Valley uh
report by Eric Christensen and uh for
gwena
so can I come
may ask for me
I'm gonna just show you D3 here okay
it's not the same
you know what our Deer Valley
I have a laser here
if I need it it's a little red thing
did you see this on the first day of
testimony uh
and James maybe do the top third
this is Chris christensen's report yes
it says a male skier took her out from
behind is that what happened yes this
report is accurate very
I didn't see it but heard her scream as
she went down do you dispute that I
don't
I ski directly to her did he do that he
did yes the man was behind her
both were in discomfort
is that all true yes
during lunch she talked of being stiff
and sore is that a true statement it is
can we go to the second third now please
I'm glad you can see it on your monitor
we had a hard time getting those going
all right I'm gonna look here
it says on the right there a patroller
came by to check on everyone do you have
a memory of that I don't honestly I'm
afraid and then the bottom third please
be on the scope of my read direct cross
Etc
uh your honor I'm addressing this
because
she was asked additional questions about
sort of where
who who hit to
first thing male skier
stated was that she meaning you appeared
right in front of him
all right did you hear that
no
uh you disputed occurred no
thus admitting he was the uphill skier
he was
she never saw him because he came in
from behind correct did you see Mr
Sanderson in front of you no he was
behind me did you have a lash in your
eye or otherwise have something
eyesight problem nope I still love 2020.
I need reading glasses though were you
blind in one eye and limited in the
other no
all right I think there's a reference
here that given your height and Mr
Sanderson
uh
less height
less being less tall but somehow you
couldn't have felt him
against your back can you just comment
on that
well he was uphill of me so he was
higher than me and he pressed whatever
of his body against my back when his
skis slid between mine where he's
still when the skis came between you no
I was gently skiing and he kind of
gently skied right into me
better than you were going no it wasn't
an impact
okay well until we hit the ground to
come up upon you yes I guess he had to
have been skiing a little faster than
you I don't know because he was behind
me so I don't know what he was doing all
right
Ramon said that Sanderson had his head
downhill spread eagle out cold Did You
observe that no was his head downhill
beyond the scope
I think you're going beyond the scope uh
your honor she asked about uh I'll move
on but she was asking about where people
were
redirect or recross so you you can go
into that thanks so you heard Ramon say
spread eagle head down right I did out
cold
do you think you would have noticed if
he had been spread eagle uh
first just comment on that yes or no
his comment like I did see him
uh spread ego or he did not I I'm trying
to be as broad as I can on that well
that's that's leading okay
it is
that is true
was your head when you came to arrest
downhill
action
so Ramon said they were both downhill
that is incorrect
I the ski the expert today even said it
was impossible for him to get lift off
and
so that's just not what happened the
comment was that you cursed it at him
why didn't you say pardon me sir I think
you inadvertently
ran into me why didn't you do that in a
nice calm manner
again I felt violated I was upset my I
was worried about my knee my back hurt
it felt violating to have somebody press
their body against my back I was full of
adrenaline I was really upset and I I'm
sorry that I cursed I think Ramon said
something like someone gave him the
stink eye your your Coldplay buddy
if it wasn't your Coldplay buddy but
gave gave him the stink eye or something
to that effect I don't remember that a
mean look
I don't know who that would have been
and I don't remember Brad probably
wasn't too happy that someone had hurt
his what his girlfriend
I'll let it go
who hit who
oh my gosh I wanna what a waste of time
so say three words your honor
go thank you thank
you thank you across it's five o'clock
we're done
thank you thank you members of the jury
um let me just give you the same
instruction that I have given you a few
times so we're recessing now until 9 A.M
on Monday morning
and so you'll be on your uh you'll be on
your own over the weekend before we
recess I need to remind you of the
following instruction
please do not discuss this case with
anyone including other jurors
please do not attempt to learn anything
about the case outside of the courtroom
including from other jurors please avoid
radio TV internet and newspaper reports
on this case
please keep an open mind throughout the
presentation of the evidence and please
do not form or Express an opinion on
this case until such time as it is
finally submitted to you for
deliberations and the final instruction
is have a great weekend
step down and you can leave too